foreign
it is a minute or so after 10 o'clock so
this is what uh representative colcum if
foreign thank you everyone for joining
our first
labor public hearings of the year a
couple things before we get started
particularly for the new people it has
been the practice for as long as I've
been on this committee that when we have
members who are sponsoring or
co-sponsoring a bill which we have a
number of today that those members who
wish to testify recuse themselves from
their seat and participate on that bill
from the audience
um members who are co-sponsors who do
not testify are free to remain in their
seats but we generally do not
ask questions and interact on a bill on
which we have sponsored I think it can
be intimidating if we're giving the
perception that we get to play both
sides of the table
um kind of in a similar way be please be
respectful of the people testifying
sometimes it's necessary to go in and
out of the committee room
unexpectedly but uh I I think if you can
please refrain from moving about while
somebody is in the middle of testimony
if you can wait until they've completed
I think that
um
remind everyone we are on being live
streamed so please make use of the
microphones so that it gets picked up
and
uh our chairman will be watching us via
live stream as is I understand his
mother so please let's conduct ourselves
accordingly
yes we do have a pretty full schedule
today it was in some part unavoidable
that we have a lot of bills that are
early bills that need to be reported in
early so we might have one or two more
than
um
I would often
be comfortable with within the time
frame so I would ask everyone both on
the committee and in the audience to
please
help us move the hearings along keep
your
testimony brief and to the point and to
the subject of the bill
um
if most people have put down the time
that they're going to speak I'd ask you
to try to stick to that
and
um
I thank you for your assistance in that
with that I'd like to open the hearing
on the first bill of the morning this is
HB 57 and it's relative to the state
minimum hourly wage
yes representative uh sorry Mr chair but
uh were you going to call a roll
uh
that was something I was going to and
I'll ask before you take your Clerk's
hat off do we typically call rule for a
public hearing I don't remember
okay
and I'll ask uh representative LeClaire
who is
going to be helping out for these first
so if you could call the roll for us
thank you
yes
okay good morning obviously uh we know
that uh chairman infantine is not here
so uh by Sherman Ryan seaworth here
represent representative abellini
representative Prout
representative love here representative
Boyd here representative Mason present
representative call Comb here
representative Drago
here
representative Granger
representative Sullivan here
representative Rudy here representative
Cahill here
representative de Silvestro
representative soucy
here representative Bouchard here
representative representative agita
representative McKenzie here
representative Schultz here and myself
thank you
much and thanks for that reminder
representative
so without further Ado I would like to
ask the representative to introduce this
Bill thank you Mr chair I had by the way
hoped to go last
um and have the kind freshman wrapped
from Manchester introduce it so I I hope
I can go last I just want to do the
introduction of the amendment and the
specifics of just the mechanics of the
bill but I'm happy to just speak now if
that's better
uh so you want to at the end you want to
talk about the amendment like the
speechifying stuff so to speak now I
just want to talk about the specifics of
the amendment and the bill to just
explain the language and what it is
and introduce it in the formal sense all
right go ahead and do that plan on
introduction and then you can come back
did you fill out a card
in between fill out the card well thank
you thank you okay without further Ado
um and there are X there were anyways
extra copies of the amendment on the
table for folks who are here
um the amendment simplifies the bill
it keeps to them to adding changes and
introducing a minimum wage back to New
Hampshire
it is in three steps uh 13.50
which would be in effect in September
then 14 25 on January 1st of next year
then fifteen dollars the subsequent year
and then every January 1st after that so
from 2026 there would be a cola based on
the Department of Labor Statistics
average for Northeast Consumer Price
Index
um because that seems the first thing to
do including if you think about
inflation today that means everyone's
dollar goes not very far but it would be
nice to be able to do that for folks who
are working hard to keep the Granite
State uh running
at one level or another
so it gets rid of the sections that
um
section two which talks about the sub
minimum wage that's not needed because
there's a separate bill coming up next
and then it gets rid of a Teenage
training wage
so really the amendment is simply
the pay pay items
thank you okay is that all now yes thank
you very much thank you since we're
supposed to wipe down the microphone
next up I'd like to call Representative
Kathy Staub speaking in support of the
bill
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for hearing my
testimony for the record my name is
Kathy Staub I live in Ward 5 in
Manchester New Hampshire and represent
Hillsborough County District 25.
um and I'm here to speak in favor of
House Bill 57 which would raise New
Hampshire's well repo re reintroduce a
minimum wage statute to the state of New
Hampshire and raise the wage from 7.25
cents an hour to two to Fifteen dollars
in 2025.
um the last time New Hampshire raised
the minimum wage was 2009.
um the federal minimum wage went up to
725 in 2010 New Hampshire's minimum wage
was 7.25 in 2009.
um at that time our minimum wage was
closely in line with other New England
states the highest minimum wage in New
England at that point was eight dollars
and 25 cents an hour so we were at 7.25
Massachusetts was at eight so it was all
fairly
um fairly close times have changed
um costs have gone up
workers have
required more money from their employers
and so at this point
um the minimum wage in Maine is 13.80
cents an hour in Massachusetts it is 15
an hour at Rhode Island is 13. Vermont
is 13.18 and Connecticut will be going
to 15 on June 1st of this year and New
Hampshire remains at 7.25 cents an hour
and
um some people will say well nobody
makes that well some people do but it
also sends a powerful message to workers
that the elected government the people
who are elected to
um to serve the people of New Hampshire
really don't
um think much about
um working people so I think it sends a
powerful message I think it would be a
very important step to take to attract
and retain workers to the state
especially young workers
2010 30 states require employers to pay
more than the federal minimum wage of
7.25 cents an hour
this year alone 23 States raise their
minimum wage several States Florida
Massachusetts California Washington
State and the District of Columbia
um our Entre well let's see
Massachusetts California Washington
State and the District of Columbia have
already reached 15 an hour several other
states are on track to 15 in the next
few years one being Florida which will
um in 2026 hit 15 Delaware in 2025
Illinois New Jersey Nebraska Florida and
Nebraska are both past minimum wage
ballot initiatives the last time a
ballot initiative to raise the minimum
wage failed was in 1996. this is a very
popular
piece of legislation in 2019 there was a
public policy polling survey that
indicated that 79 percent of people in
this voters in the state were in favor
of raising the minimum wage to
um twelve dollars an hour and 63 percent
were in favor of raising the minimum
wage to Fifteen dollars an hour and that
was you know that was four years ago so
times have changed prices have gone up
and people recognize that working people
need to make a living wage
um speaking of the living wage
um
according to the MIT calculator a single
person would need to make
17.32 cents an hour to live a decent
life in New Hampshire a couple with one
child both working would need to make
18.56 an hour in a single person with
one child would need to make 33.91 cents
an hour in order to
meet the needs of themselves and their
family
I came here because you know I live in
Ward five
um I have a lot of hard-working people
in my ward who don't make a lot of money
because they're working in jobs like
grocery store cashier they're working in
nursing homes taking care of elderly and
disabled people
they're very important to our
um
our economy in the city of Manchester
South Willow Street generates a lot of
of revenue for the for the state through
uh
you know business tax profits taxes and
these people work really hard they
contribute to the the state and um they
deserve a decent quality of life and I
think that that's my main motivation I
know we're not supposed to talk about
motivation but my motivation in being a
state representative is to
um make sure that decent hard-working
people who live in my district have a
decent quality of life and that is why
I'm a co-sponsor of this bill and that's
why I'm in favor of passing a minimum
wage statute and and you know bringing
New Hampshire into the 21st century
um with and that's really all I have to
say I'm happy to take questions
thank you very much are there questions
for the representative yes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um will raising the minimum wage
cause job loss and increased
unemployment
thank you for the question
representative
um over the years I think Maine passed a
ballot initiative and their minimum wage
is very close to ours and when they did
raise their minimum wage there was no
job loss in fact there were a number of
new jobs added there was a study done in
Maine which I can email to the members
of the um I'll email a link to the
members of the committee if you like
also another indicator would be looking
at unemployment rates which I have
included in my data sheet New
Hampshire's current as of November of
2022 Ms McGraw from the Department of
Labor may have more recent statistics
but in 2022 November of 2022 New
Hampshire had a 2.6 unemployment rate
Connecticut with a close was it 4.2
percent Maine at three
Massachusetts 3.4 Rhode Island 3.6
Vermont which has a much higher minimum
wage of 13.00 18 cents an hour had a
lower unemployment rate than we did at
2.5 the only other state in the
Northeast with a 7.25 minute minimum
wage is Pennsylvania and their
unemployment rate is four percent
so um it you know it doesn't appear that
I'm raising the minimum wage has a
terrible impact on unemployment I will
say that many people believe that an
unemployment rate around three percent
indicates a labor shortage and you don't
need the statistics
to understand that yes indeed we do have
a labor shortage in the state of New
Hampshire so you know and I think
attracting more workers retaining more
workers you know people along the border
could be working in New Hampshire but
they can make you know if they're living
in Salem they can drive across the
border to Methuen and make a minimum of
fifteen dollars an hour which you know
is not guaranteed here in New Hampshire
oh please thank you
um do you know how many people are
making under 15 an hour
uh yeah well it's
um the economic policy Institute in 2021
um believed I mean this is all a moving
Target we've seen that wages have been
going up and
um in an unprecedented way because of
this labor shortage that we have in 2021
the economic policy Institute estimated
that about 150 000 workers in the state
of New Hampshire would benefit from a 15
minimum wage I am unsure if that number
is still accurate because that was over
a year ago and as I said it's a moving
Target they they believe that about 22
percent of the at that point 22 percent
of the entire Workforce of the state
would um
would benefit from a 15 an hour minimum
wage as of June of 22 the average entry
level wage was 14.32 cents an hour which
is close to 15. so if you were this bill
would raise the wage to 13.50
um in in 2023 uh in September and um you
know that wouldn't even hit that number
but one of the things that you need to
consider is that the distance between
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour and
that 14 an hour is is pretty small and
and and and the other end of it
um you know people can be have a
starting wage in a job at thirty dollars
an hour and that that really skews it
high so there are probably a lot more
people who are making less than than in
terms of numbers making less than 14.36
an hour than there are people who are
thank you
uh and yes if you could send that link
to the committee email I think we'd
appreciate that are there any other
questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimonies
next I would like to ask Maria Perez uh
good morning Mr chairman and good
morning members of the committee my name
is Maria Perez I'm a state
representative from District 43 Milford
New Hampshire
I'm here in support of the bill now more
than ever is critical for us to
understand why we need to increase the
minimum wage
if we want to talk about
the crisis that we have housing crisis
increase in the minimum wage is going to
help us
a lot of the people that we see homeless
a lot of the people that we see
suffering right now with mental health
is because it's hard it's hard for
people to work two to three jobs and
still not making enough to have a place
to live a place that can call home
it's hard for people to have family with
three or four kids and they still don't
have enough money to pay for food
we have a lot of kids to go to school
without having breakfast or lunch or
dinner because the parents they have to
decide in between paying for the rent or
paying for food in many cases paying for
medication
I heard a lot of comments and I hear a
lot of times people saying well we're
going to hurt businesses
businesses they're getting hurt right
now
because people decided not to work in
the industries what they get and pay
less than nine dollars an hour and they
move into industries that they can get
paid 15 to 20 dollars an hour
I have uh spoke to some businesses in my
town
that they're having a hard time getting
people to work in the restaurant
industry
because they don't want to make
under 15 16 an hour
because they know that's not enough
if we talk about how much they have to
pay for rent
some of the apartments in 1750
1750 for one bedroom
we're talking about 22.50 for two
bedroom apartment
how in the world people gonna pay 22
hundred dollars a month in rent when
they're still making 7.25 nine dollars
an hour and please do not tell me that
people don't make 7.25 an hour because I
spoke to someone who worth 52 hours
and still make almost no money because
725 that's what she got paid
so I'm here in support because it is
time for us to
think about people as a humans
no money maker machines the industries
more Rich every day by the poor people
I saw it on my own eyes the crisis that
we have right now with the homeless
population here in New Hampshire I was
there all day if we want to fix they
have the homeless situation and we want
to fix the mental health and other
issues in our state let's talk about the
minimum wage thank you for your time and
I'm more than happy to take any
questions
thank you representative for your
I see none so thank you again
um next up I would like to call Claudia
Estelle
speaking for yourself yes thank you
good morning
members of the labor committee thank you
for listening to my testimony in support
of HB 57 I'm Claudia Estelle from New
Hampshire Acworth New Hampshire sorry
um in my experience talking with voters
about their concerns the economy is
often mentioned in discussing the
minimum wage there's often disbelief and
dismay that New Hampshire doesn't have a
minimum wage and relies on the federal
minimum wage of 7.25 cents an hour which
has not been raised since 2009 over 13
years ago and during which time
inflation has increased by more than 24
percent
with the labor market pressures these
voters are sure that no one still earns
the minimum wage however according to
the Bureau of Labor Statistics 9 000 New
Hampshire workers earned for 7.25 an
hour or less this is only 2.3 percent of
the New Hampshire Workforce but for
these workers the market forces are not
working
many workers earn more than the minimum
wage but still a hundred and fifty
thousand New Hampshire workers earn less
than fifteen dollars an hour that's
about 20 percent of the workforce or one
in five workers these workers are not
earning enough to cover basic needs of
housing food clothing Medical Care and
transportation they are eligible for
Public Assistance programs these safety
net programs were designed to help
people in temporary and unusually
unfortunate circumstances not as a way
to make ends meet every month
these programs are paid for by taxpayers
like the workers who rely on them and
like all of us here and why are we
subsidizing businesses so that they can
increase their profits
those I spoke with found these facts
concerning but countered with well if
wages go up prices will rise even more
hurting everyone
not so according to the economic policy
Institute they estimate that raising the
federal minimum wage to Fifteen dollars
an hour would Inc lift wages for 32
million workers across the country at a
cost of 1
108 billion dollars a huge sum but only
0.7 percent less than one percent of the
16 trillion dollars that U.S customers
annually spend
they're consumers excuse me and so even
if the race was made in one year and
most bills including this one propose
incremental increases the effect on
prices would be less than one percent
another comment was that workers who
want to improve their income can pursue
Education and Training for better paying
jobs many workers have done this
resulting in worker shortages and
essential jobs from Highway workers to
retail sales clerks to nursing
assistants from school bus drivers to
substitute teachers and
paraprofessionals many states many find
the stress and lack of support in these
essential occupations combined with low
pay to be demoralizing stressful at all
on one's physical and mental health as
they constantly worry about making ends
meet
the national employment law project and
the economic policy Institute found that
wages were below the cost of living in
New Hampshire for the following
occupations weight staff fast food cooks
and workers dishwashers cashiers
substitute teachers restaurant hostesses
laundry workers child care workers
retail salespersons housekeeping
cleaners home health care aids nursing
assistants teaching assistants and
paramedics
we need these people for our society to
function if we deem that they are
essential shouldn't we respect them with
a decent wage
inflation is a big concern now we can
all talk about how increases in price of
food electricity Fuel and other items of
wreak havoc with our budgets the people
who are most affected are low-wage
workers who spend all their income on
essential items like food housing and
energy
they can barely make ends meet in 2020
and use pandemic relief checks to cover
basic expenses now they are stretched
more stressed and suffering they're
relying even more on food pantries
Church relief funds and Public
Assistance programs
as they spend all their income in local
stores and businesses they build and
strengthen our state state economy they
are also the ones most affected by
higher prices because so many of them
work in retail and service jobs
consumers will first cut back on eating
out haircuts buying extras and low-wage
workers in service and Retail will be
among the first to see their hours and
jobs cut
if we believe that everyone should be
able to stand up on their own two feet
then we should support paying workers
enough so that they can do that a living
wage in New Hampshire is at least 17 an
hour according to the MIT living wage
calculator so this bill is conservative
move in the right direction please
support HB 57 to reinstate the minimum
wage in New Hampshire and raise it to 15
an hour by 2025. thank you thank you
very much for your testimony are there
questions
yes sir
these are not um oh it's got to be red
yeah politics thank you Mr chair thank
you for your time today
um so you gave some numbers about the
number of people making uh sub minimum
wages uh does that include tipped
workers
um
I'm not sure the I I would assume
possibly because it said less than 27.25
an hour but I haven't read the full
report carefully I have the the link to
it on my testimony okay thank you
are there other questions for this
Witness
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
next up I would like to ask the Reverend
Dr Gail Kinney
speaking in support of the bill three
minutes of testimony and she represents
the New Hampshire United Church of
thank you
so good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee um thank you for taking
the time to hear my testimony today
um so I am speaking on behalf of the
United Church of Christ economic Justice
team but in addition to our team
um our entire denomination which is the
largest Protestant denomination in the
state of New Hampshire went on record
about
um
eight years ago as a denomination
um being in support then of increasing
the minimum wage in New Hampshire and
then with restoring the minimum wage
after it was wiped off the state
statutes so I am also a resident of
Canaan and I would say as
as a church pastor
um I am one of the the many pastors who
are on the front lines of witnessing and
dealing with
um individuals in our midst who are
low-wage workers from low-wage working
families and we see every day the trauma
that occurs
um because of the challenges the the
tremendous challenges of of these
low-wage workers in New Hampshire trying
to just make ends meet and trying to
survive so we're certainly talking about
those several thousand that are making
7.25 an hour but we're also talking
about the many thousands of New
Hampshire workers who are making 9 10 11
12 an hour and uh are just sort of one
crisis one small uh car repair bill or
health setback away from really being in
severe economic crisis and um so they
turned to the churches but this is not
sustainable and this is not good public
policy but I want to take a slightly
different direction as well and the
argument is or the argument that I have
heard over the years you know since 2011
or 12 I think when the minimum wage was
eliminated in New Hampshire was well the
market will provide don't worry the
market will provide and maybe sometimes
the market does provide except when it
doesn't
um and I would say that even the
McDonald's corporation several years ago
in 2019 withdrew from a National
Coalition of of major employers Across
the Nation who were trying to suppress
the minimum wage and we're arguing
against any change because they realized
it was not good for their business so
they announced on that they were
withdrawing from that Coalition because
they were realizing that the market and
the message that being conveyed by that
Coalition was not healthy economically
so
um
when the market doesn't work for the
many thousands of New Hampshire workers
who are still making low wages
um then the message that we send is that
we don't care about the the many
thousands of New Hampshire workers who
care for our elderly who care for our
young and who are doing so much
Essential full-time work and yet they
still can't survive economically let
alone Thrive and it should not make us
proud as the state of New Hampshire be
to to be known as the stingy State or
the heartless State surrounded by other
states in New England or the Northeast
who approach wage policy in a completely
different way
um so there was a recent news article I
I saw a headline
um and I'm not sure if a way that asks
the question will New Hampshire
legislators this year address the
workforce shortage and I would just say
to you that clinging to the federal wage
of 725 uh is not a message that attracts
young workers it's not a message that
will help cure the workforce short
shortage what it does is it sends a
message on to workers to flee to go
across the borders and to work elsewhere
so I just implore you if this
legislature if this committee and this
legislature cares about the economic
health of our state if you care about
the needs of New Hampshire employers
who need to your help in putting forth
an image of New Hampshire being an
inviting place for good workers then
that speaks to the need to set a wage
floor just a wage floor saying this is a
figure below which New Hampshire will
not go in terms of rewarding full-time
work for adult workers and so in order
to have a reliable dedicated Workforce
it matters to the granite state that we
articulate a wage floor that's what this
bill does and so on behalf of my faith
the nomination and the many other people
of Faith wishes of Faith with whom I
work every day I would encourage you
implore you to find House Bill 57 ought
to pass
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions
seeing none thank you again
next up I would like to call Bruce
Berkey he is speaking in opposition to
the bill
uh for three minutes he represents the
national Federation of Independent
Business
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee Happy New Year to everyone and
welcome back to those that have been
here and welcome to the new members
uh my name is Bruce Berkey I'm the state
director for the national Federation of
Independent Business an organization
that has over 1400 small businesses
throughout the state and these are the
smallest of the small businesses these
are businesses that have between one and
ten sometimes 15 employees they're
they're small businesses they're not the
the large corporations that that some
people have spoken of
and nfib is opposed to Senate Bill 57
and primarily because it injects an
artificial standard into a process into
an economy in which the business
Community prefers a open market
and more often than not an artificial
standard will disrupt that market
how you may ask what are the
consequences
and what Studies have shown
is that when there are artificial
standards increased minimum wages
fewer jobs do result
fewer hours for those current employees
result
it accelerates automation therefore
diminishing the need for additional
employees
hurting the very people that sponsors
are seeking to help here
and
the most telling point I think
is what's called wage compression and we
haven't heard of that this morning
but if you have employees now and
believe me employees are making 15 18 an
hour to start throughout the state of
New Hampshire I can speak specifically
to the ski industry who we do work for
and there's no one working at a skier in
the state of New Hampshire for less than
fifteen dollars an hour
so what happens when an artificial rate
gets put into the equation
for wages
when a minimum wage gets increased to
13.50 or to Fifteen dollars an hour
that person that started six months ago
or four months ago at fifteen dollars an
hour all of a sudden is saying wait a
minute I shouldn't be making minimum
wage I've been working I now deserve a
raise
and that creates a higher cost for the
employer
it causes some unrest perhaps within the
workforce of that particular employer
and it is it just does not create a
positive environment within the business
community
in addressing the amendment uh that
representative Schultz put forward
um if the spill was to pass
uh
there was one good piece in it and that
was the training wage
nfib has supported training wages over
the years
and if this bill were to go forward
we would
um encourage this committee to maintain
the training wage language that's built
into the original bill
with that Mr chairman I'd be happy to
try and address any questions and thank
you for your time thank you are there
questions for
yes representative uh thank you uh
so the the question I have for you
relates to what is a bigger problem the
lack of people available to work are the
wages that are being paid in other words
would
would employers if they had a good pool
of people uh be better off does the
minimum wage
impact that in any way
the minimum wage at what level in other
words
yeah it's a bigger problem for employers
is the lack of people available to work
today opposed to the minimum wage
so so you have a follow-up
representative that's it okay today that
is the case I mean there is a shortage
of workers and there's a strong economy
right now in terms of you know job
availability is is you know strong and
the the wage structure right now for
workers throughout the state of New
Hampshire is strong
and and so you know we're we're hopeful
that we're not going to see a
large leap in the in the minimum wage
rate
that's going to bump up against what
people are receiving now in wages and
create that wage compression that I
any other questions for this wedding
yes this representative thank you Mr
chair I know how to use the button now
uh so with the businesses that you work
with do they often so if they're having
a hard time finding employees they often
respond to that by raising the wages in
which they give new hires yes
thank you
other questions representative
thank you for taking my question
um as as I look at this on July 1st 2023
uh the minimum wage will increase about
80 percent
um could you address the uh the the
devastation that had happened to the the
employer that has 15 20 employees uh you
know how many would be going out of
business uh how many uh how many jobs
would be eliminated uh and and that type
of stuff I I think it's uh I I won't
speak to specifics right here today but
the impact of a large increase like that
on a small business is going to make
that employer you know look at you know
the the hour structure that he has for
his or he or she has for their employees
uh it's going to look at you know
whether new jobs are going to be added
it's going to look at you know the the
wage compression issue is Big
um so there are consequences
thank you
any further questions
can you explain wage compression to me
sure
representative McKenzie thank you
if if I have five employees
and they're making between 13 and 15 an
hour today
and the minimum wage today is 7.25 and
on I believe it's September 1st the 23
the rate goes up to
um
1350 or so uh
that person who's at 13 today obviously
gets a raise of 15 of 50 cents an hour
and that person who you know may have
been there 12 or 18 months with the
employer who's at 15 an hour today
is going to say
that person you know that just started
last week at 13 an hour gonna raise a 50
50 cents
and you know I was making you know much
more than the minimum wage he's going to
go he or she's going to go to their
employer and say I deserve a raise now
because I shouldn't be making you know
almost right at the minimum wage I
should be making much more than the
minimum wage and that's the compression
the upward compression on the overall
representative these default these
Silvestro I'm sorry okay thank you for
tell me how it is that New Hampshire
can't seem to move forward with this but
the other states how do they handle it
with their small businesses
I I won't speak for you know Vermont
Maine or Massachusetts or other states
um all I can say is that New Hampshire
today has the strongest economy in the
Northeast
and it is uh been beneficial for
employees it's been beneficial for
employers and uh we're we're hopeful
that that you know open market free
market
um process will continue and allow that
Mr Burkey just just to go back to that
compression issue once more
uh wouldn't it be something an option
for the employer to say well that's this
is not a merit increase it's not because
that that person is working as well as
you are you you're working your
experience but that the legislature in
its wisdom has raised the minimum wage
and and if other employers don't don't
succumb to the pressure to raise the
wage then wouldn't it be wouldn't it
roughly stay the same the 15 person
would continue to make fifteen dollars
not necessarily influenced by the raise
to or 1350.
and any
yeah
any any number of scenarios can happen
there representative Caitlin and I
appreciate your question I think what
what I'm trying to say is that you know
the the person who is making 15 and all
of a sudden is just making a dollar more
or a dollar fifty more than the minimum
wage
is going to you know feel
you know disappointed hey I I was hired
you know because of my skills because of
my capabilities at 15 an hour and now
that the minimum wage is at 13.50 and
going to be at 14 I ought to be making
you know 18 or 20 an hour and and that's
that's the rub there and sure the
employer can decide not to increase that
15 an hour employee but it's going to
create
um you know some unrest some
disappointment within the workforce and
you know
despite what you hear out there
employers like their employees and they
want to you know have a positive
environment because that's going to be
representative thanks to take my
question uh I just texted one of my
County Commissioners and I asked him uh
what the the starting wage for a an LNA
and um
you know he he texted back he said he
thinks it's 13.50 would it be safe to
say that because the minimum wage is
going up six six dollars an hour that
these thirteen fifty dollars thirteen
fifty an hour employees would not want
1950 and the the the impact on our
County budgets uh would Skyrocket
history would certainly suggest that
representative love thank you
thank you
um and just we're we're getting to the
edge of we're not here to explain to the
witnesses what we know we're here to
listen to them so
uh representative McKenzie thank you um
can you uh is your position of your
organization is that there should be no
no
so do you support any increase in
minimum wage at all putting it back on
the books
we we do not support an increase in the
minimum wage there is no minimum wage
well I remember please to that end
representative McKenzie we would
um and I believe that they have there is
a National Organization for nfib I
believe that they have opposed minimum
I guess Mr chairman that's really not
the question I asked the question I ask
is does your organization support
minimum wage of any kind in the state of
New Hampshire
they have not taken a position on
whether it should be on the books or not
thank you
are there any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh next I would like to call
and and pardon me I'm obviously having
trouble with names this morning I'd like
to call viola katasimi
um who is representing the granite state
organizing project and has signed up for
two minutes
good morning members of the House
committee for the record my name is
Viola katsime and I'm here representing
the granite state organizing project we
are a graduate organization that brings
people of Faith labor Community groups
to work towards a more just world I'm
here to express our support for HP 57
relative to that minimum hourly wage
we're here in support because we're
talking about a bill that would
gradually increase could could you move
the microphone a little closer some
people weren't is this better that is
better thank you thank you uh we are
here to express our support for HB 57
relative to the hourly minimum wage
we're here in support because we're
talking about a bill that would
gradually increase the minimum wage from
Seven dollars an hour to Fifteen dollars
an hour by 2025 and index that to
inflation after 2026.
this is not a radical policy
if the minimum wage had kept up with
productivity
it would be more than 22 an hour
and that's according to an analysis that
has been done by the economic policy
Institute but instead New Hampshire has
decided to take a backseat and allow a
minimum wage to fall to the predominium
wage of 7.25
which hasn't been raised since 2009.
think about that year
no prices have stayed that the same
since 2009. in 2019 raised up New
Hampshire which is a coalition that I
work with we run a minimum wage
challenge we invited legislators who
were present at the time to live in the
shoes of avoid minimum workers
we asked them if they could leave on
wages for for people that are making
7.25 cents an hour for a week
guess what we did not get a lot of
responses I see some faces in this room
who'd attempted that challenge and they
came back to us and said it was very
difficult they could not even get by on
groceries for a week so imagine so many
of our workers in the states a previous
speaker spoke about the fact that we
have about 9 000 workers in the state of
New Hampshire who are getting 7.25 cents
an hour so imagine what their lives are
like
we know that food prices housing costs
child care costs healthcare costs have
all risen drastically
but what has State stagnant is our
minimum wage
to put this into contacts if you're a
single worker on minimum wage in New
Hampshire you need to be working at
least over actually 100 hours a week to
afford a one-bedroom apartment and we're
talking about a median rent of twelve
hundred dollars
that's if you don't want to pay more
than 30 percent of your income to
housing which is what affordable housing
is according Todd
uh but let's say that samwaka has more
than one child
which means they'll need two-bedroom
apartment that same work at 7.25 cents
an hour would be need would need to work
at least 145 hours a week
um I also have a live example grind
State organizing project runs a tenant
clinic since the pandemic we've been
seeing a lot of cases of people getting
evicted and in this tenant Clinic every
day we work with tenants finding
assistance for them we hear stories from
families
there's a a worker currently working in
the Mall of New Hampshire at 16 an hour
she has to work 50 hours a week
to be able to qualify for a one bedroom
apartment if she doesn't have those 10
hours she doesn't qualify and what
that's what that means is that she's
homeless she has nowhere to stay
so this is definitely a contributing
factor to the homeless crisis that we're
seeing across the state so I want you to
consider the factors of workers in the
ground state especially with rent with
the cost of housing Child Care
Transportation
um I won't go back to the numbers
because they've already been shared
earlier by the previous speakers
but also to put into contacts we had
representative stop mentioned about the
living wage I encourage all of you to
try out the MIT living wage calculator
and look at what is needed for people in
your region you can pull up your phone
so after this I'd like you to do the
research and see the numbers for
yourselves
you need to be earning at least 17 an
hour if you're a single worker without
kids and of course if you have kids that
that number is much higher
so I just want to conclude by saying
that raising the minimum wage 15 an hour
uh would be would would benefit greatly
people of color uh black people Hispanic
people women uh you'd also pay uh
increase the workers of it would also
increase the rate that pay for essential
workers
um who most of us really thanked during
the pandemic who are keeping our
students running I know nursing homes
going
uh increasing the minimum wage you've
all noticed that a lot of workers who
are low-wage workers when they get money
they tend to spend that money in the
economy so this money is not going to be
used to buy second homes or invested in
the stock market it's going to
be getting your hair done or getting uh
going to a dinner date so it does
support businesses so I urge committee
members uh support HP 57
and
so therefore what has New Hampshire can
afford an adequate standard of living
that's the basic and the minimum that
this committee should do thank you thank
you for your testimony are there
questions
uh thank you Mr chair
um you said you mentioned a mall worker
um Can Can you I I think I might have
missed part of that could you quickly
clarify uh she so was she getting 16 an
hour she gets 16 an hour uh but for hard
qualify for a one bedroom apartment she
had to justify her income and there's no
way she could justify qualifying for a
one-bedroom apartment without showing
that over time hours which is the 10
hours a week that she has to work
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
next I would like to call Reverend Heidi
Heath representing the New Hampshire
Council of churches speaking in support
of the bill
uh you didn't put down a Time
but
I will keep my remarks to three minutes
thank you very much
honorable members of the committee thank
you for hearing my testimony today I am
the Reverend Heidi Carrington Heath I
serve as the executive director of the
New Hampshire Council of churches
we represent nine denominations and
hundreds of congregations across the
granite state
I rise today to ask you to consider a
vote of ought to pass on HB 57 to raise
our state's minimum wage
in the context of my work I visit
congregations across the state
and I hear the stories of people in Rich
varied and diverse communities
they cannot afford to feed their
families
they cannot afford to make ends meet
our minimum wage in New Hampshire is
functionally a poverty wage
it is not just or ethical
it does not care for or regard the worth
and dignity of our citizens
we rank dead last in New England for
states with a livable wage
the federal minimum wage was raised to
725 in 2009.
14 years ago
that was not a fair wage in 2009 and it
is absolutely not a fair wage in 2023
you have heard the statistics from
multiple sources this morning and New
Hampshire's own economic and labor
market Bureau tell us similarly over 20
percent of our Workforce are working for
under 15 an hour that's over a hundred
thousand of our neighbors our friends
people we care about
as a Christian minister I am committed
to an ethic of thriving and justice for
all of my neighbors in the granite state
they cannot Thrive we cannot Thrive
without a living minimum wage
today we have an easy opportunity to
take a step to join our New England
Neighbors in raising the wage
low-wage workers are of deep essential
and high value to the Granite State they
deserve to be paid a living wage for
their work
in my tradition we would say that they
are created we are created in the image
of God
all workers must be able to support
themselves and their families and live
with the dignity the life of wholeness
that is intended for all of us we have a
chance to move toward that reality today
thank you for your time please consider
a vote of ought to pass on HB 57.
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you again
next I would ask Grace kandiki
can Decay I'm sorry
um representing afsc speaking in support
of the bill for two minutes
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the committee for taking my testimony my
name is Grace condecke I'm the program
coordinator of the American front
service committee and I'm coming here
today to uh to in support of HB 57
and so I'm also in addition to doing my
work with afsc I am a long time granted
Stater I grew up in Manchester where I
live now with my husband and young
sister
I've had a job since I was in elementary
school I think many of us can reflect
back to our first positions our first
jobs that we had
and I had my first bills when I was a
teenager
I want to reflect I want to share a
story about the last time that I earned
7.25 an hour and I'd like you all to
kind of take down a walk down memory
lane with me and reflect on when was the
last time you earned 725 an hour had to
live off of that income
the last time I earned 7.25 an hour was
in 2012.
my then boyfriend who is now my husband
both of us worked five to six jobs
between the two of us I wish our bills
were artificial because then we wouldn't
have had to work so many jobs in order
to make ends meet
I worked occasionally as an art model I
worked occasionally in a restaurant and
I also worked part-time as an attendant
at a local gym in Nashua all for minimum
wage
in comparison to today's prices living
expenses were low for us and still my
partner and I struggled to make our
bills to be able to pay what we needed
every month even though we combined our
incomes and he was fortunate enough to
live at home with his family while I
shared a two-bedroom apartment a small
one in Manchester with a roommate
this was unsustainable and a year later
I would move to Boston where I would
finally get my first job that would pay
me 15 an hour
raising the minimum wage not only brings
us on par with our regional neighbors it
would also make us go be it would also
make us competitive as a state and it
would go a long way to not only support
New Hampshire workers strengthen our
social fabric it would also go a long
way to retaining the talent and the
skills of the young people of our state
who are often overrepresented in the
number of workers who are paid at or
near minimum wage I have many friends
over the last couple of years who have
had to leave or are considering leaving
New Hampshire because they simply cannot
afford to live here on the wages that
they earn here
I couldn't live off of minimum wage then
and with the Steep increases in prices
in both food and gas and rent putting
being able to make your bills every
month the hard-working people of New
Hampshire can't live off of minimum wage
now just like they could I couldn't live
off one then
the minimum amount one must earn in
order to house yourself and to take care
of your basic needs is not an artificial
standard it's just math
this is not a competition between
employers and employees raising the
minimum wage would go a long way to
strengthening the fabric and the network
and the relationships in our economy and
so I urge you to pass HP 57.
whether we do it now or we do it later
we must be able to provide for our
communities thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
I see none so thank you again
next up and I'm not quite sure I can
read this I I would ask for Reverend
Jonathan
uh representing gsop
speaking in support of the bill for two
minutes good morning thank you all for
having me here this morning and
listening to my testimony I am the
pastor of Concordia Lutheran Church here
in Concord and a church is a member of
the Granite State organizing project
would you say your last name Jonathan
Hopkins h-o-p-k-i-n-s thank you you're
welcome
uh yeah I speak as one of my colleagues
did as somebody on the front lines who
comes in contact with people living on
the edge of homelessness or are homeless
people who come to our congregation
looking for help
looking for help for rent for gas for
utilities for all sorts of things and as
my former colleague said it is untenable
our church is uh has some money that we
use to help people but it is limited
um and so but the other thing I want to
say is having all these uh meeting all
these folks who are on the edge or
homeless I will say most of them have
jobs
uh I have actually driven people from
the homeless shelter in the morning to
their job at Target or at friendlies I
have
served at our soup kitchen here in
Concord and seen people come through
with their Walmart shirts on after work
and I don't I might be crazy possible
but I just believe if you work you
should have enough money to buy food and
have have shelter I think that's a basic
human thing so what is the problem well
we know housing's too high that's part
of the problem and I would also argue
from being with families our church
participates in a homeless program for
families where we house them in our
congregation four times a year
that talking to those families the two
things that are keeping them from being
self-sufficient are a good paying job
people can find a job but a good paying
job that actually pays rent and housing
costs those are the two things and I
would suggest that is all of your that's
why you're we're sent here it to Concord
to do that work to help people who are
living on the edge to be self-sufficient
thank you thank you very much are there
questions
seeing none thank you thank you
next up I would like to call Henry vayu
representing nhlra speaking in
opposition to the bill for three minutes
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Henry vayu and I'm here on behalf of the
New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association and we come in to this
discussion in a unique perspective with
regards to the tip wage
so the minimum wage obviously is there
obviously to protect low wage workers
but when it comes to tipped employees
they certainly aren't low wage workers
you go to any restaurant and the highest
paid in the restaurant are those in the
front of the house the servers making
you know on average between 19 and 25 an
hour in a in a mid uh range restaurant
casual dining restaurant
um so we don't think there's a need to
address tip wage workers
we get involved in this discussion
because the minimum wage statute has a
minimum cash wage that the employer pays
to the server and that's in the statute
and in the proposed amendment
representative Schultz includes tipped
employees as getting the CPI adjusted
annually
tip workers already see their wages
increase annually I was speaking
yesterday
with an operator who has a number of
locations around the state
and he's increased his menu prices since
1984 three percent annually so that it's
a nice slow creep up that the customer
doesn't even realize and with chip
workers they get paid a percentage of
the meal at the price of the meal and so
they already see their wages increase
annually
so for that reason
and Mr Berkey did a good job of speaking
to the minimal age itself so I won't get
into that but we would oppose this bill
in the amendment as presented
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions
yes representative
I'll ask you a similar question to that
of Mr Burkey so is the position of your
organization there should be no minimum
wage in the state
um
I don't I don't want to speak to that
portion I largely wanted to address the
tip wage
um and uh the fact that we don't think
that um the legislation should address
the tip wage
a quick follow-up question please
follow us the current uh situation
regarding tip wages is that the
um
every employer in the state of New
Hampshire is responsible for paying the
federal minimum wage which is 7.25.
and the in the case of Tiff workers they
make uh they make their wages are much
less and so it is the tips that offset
the employee's responsibility to the uh
to the tip wage is that correct so uh
the tips are wages in the statute it
says that tips are wages that the
property the employee
um they get the employer pays the FICA
tax on those wages on those tips the
tipped servers are required to report
those to the employer and the employer
thank you yeah is there another question
uh
representative adjutant you are a
co-sponsor of this bill I was not
mindful of that earlier but thank you
very much for your cooperation
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Vegas good to see you once again uh I
recall hearing a testimony
uh during an earlier talk about tip
wages and minimum wage that restaurants
raise their prices six percent annually
but I still question whether or not a
person should earn based on the price of
the meal that they deliver to the table
is that is that fear in your in your
mind is is the is the person who uh
brings you a breakfast in a diner
working less hard than the person who
brings you your meal at a you know white
table cloth restaurant
um that's a good question
um I think if you asked folks in the
back of the house
whether they'd like in the back of the
house meaning uh in the kitchen area
those aren't tipped employees whether
they'd rather work in the front of the
house and earn what those in the front
of the house earn I think you would find
that a lot of people in the back of the
house would like to work in the front of
the house and earn those types of wages
follow up follow up have you considered
a rotation so that the people could get
an equal Taste of uh back in front of
the house
um I'm sure uh different restaurant
operators have different practices and I
I don't know whether that occurs in some
or not
thank you any further questions
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um our customers legally required to tip
uh no there's nothing in the statue that
requires them to but
um again if you look at what uh is
reported and what employers pay the the
taxes on uh customers are tipping
follow-up yes
um
what impact does the fact that someone's
working for tips what impact does that
have on their work environment
um I've heard a talk of harassment and
that type of thing in order to uh
enduring harassment in order to maintain
their
hopefully maintain their tips
um
I don't I would suggest talking with uh
servers in restaurants in your district
and find out whether they would rather
get just a flat 15 minimum with no tips
or
um
the cash wage plus the tips in Maine I
was going to save this for the next turn
but in Maine when they did away with the
tip wage
back in 2016
they restored in 2017 there were over
500 servers that showed up at the
hearing because they didn't want to do
away with that kind of practice and the
legislature in Maine restored the tip
any further questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
okay
next I would ask
um or Stephen nass who represents the
Free State Food Network he is in
opposition to the bill and signed up for
three minutes
thank you uh Stephen Ness of Milton New
Hampshire like I uh put on the card I
represent the Free State Food Network
which is a network of about 50 members
uh that are Professionals in the food
industry uh they range from servers
bartenders managers and restaurant tours
as well as chefs I myself own a
restaurant and I'm the chef of a small
restaurant on uh Seacoast and New
Hampshire here uh I really appreciated
the economic reality that some of the
previous opposition to this bill brought
up so I thought I'd talk about my own
anecdotal lived experience and try and
hit on some uh ideas that haven't been
um myself I uh came up through the
restaurant business uh as a young adult
and started at the lowest rungs working
for minimum wage and slowly worked my
way up until I was able to uh afford to
start my own restaurant so I can
personally attest to the experience of
working for minimum wage
I could say here in New Hampshire right
now all restaurants are hiring uh if
somebody is looking for work in a
restaurant they can definitely just show
up with no experience and get hired
right now and I can attest to uh
dishwashers at least on the Sea Coast
where I live are making double minimum
wage with no experience they just need
to show up occasionally and generally
get the work done and they're going to
make double minimum wage so I find it a
little bit telling
um
that no people working for minimum wage
were brought in to testify today because
I believe that that number is extremely
slim
um I think if you were to ask and we've
been talking about tipped workers
especially if you were I can attest that
if you were to ask tipped workers
servers bartenders and the like in this
state which they would prefer tips or no
tips universally they will want the
tipped wage because uh I can confirm
that the tipped workers are making more
money than just about anybody else in
the business uh oftentimes more than the
owners themselves
I worked for a year at a restaurant that
has now gone under that attempted to do
away with tipped wages and pay servers
uh flat fee or a flat a flat wage as
though they were in the back of house
and in order to do so they did have to
pay 25 35 an hour uh while the kitchen
staff was getting paid 15 16 17 18 an
hour and the result was uh wait staff
that complained constantly about how
little they were making and how much
work they had to do
um
fighting over the various shifts that
because they wanted to work the slowest
shifts because they're going to make the
same amount of money as though they were
working the busier shifts which are
actually more valuable to the business
and at the end of the day we ended up
having to bring tipped wages back and uh
eventually the business did close
because we were unable to well a
multitude of reasons but in part uh the
servers couldn't get brought back down
to their lower wages and add-on tips
they had to add on tips with their new
higher wages but uh uh to kind of pivot
to another uh
area that hasn't been talked about
um
we've spoken about uh if we raise
minimum wage that the wages will have to
rise for other workers with uh wage
compression which is definitely a very
real uh reality there but we haven't
talked about uh losing the workers uh at
the bottom end who might be making
minimum wage now
um
that if we were to raise minimum wage
the businesses wouldn't be no longer
able to support those workers
um
and I can give a personal anecdote of
this I have a special needs sister my
older sister has Down syndrome and she's
always had a hard time finding work
because uh
she's not the greatest worker and she
never will be uh but uh it's a lot
easier for her to find work if we can
negotiate lower wages because it's for
her it's much more important to have a
job than to make a high amount of money
in that job it's much more important for
her to have skills and uh do things
throughout the day that keep her mind
engaged and keep her interacting with
the public than it is to try and make
the quote Living wage
when when minimum wage Rises these these
uh employers who maybe they're just
asking to do simple tasks like put
bottles into boxes of like uh beer
sampler cases or stock shelves where she
can go at her own pace and you know it
doesn't have to be the most perfect work
because it's easily corrected
um
if if now all of a sudden we're saying
she needs to make say fifteen dollars an
hour uh these businesses aren't going to
want to take a risk and hire her anymore
they're going to let her go and and
either uh have nobody do that or have a
robot do that job or pay somebody that's
more skilled is going to do it faster so
it would directly uh harm my family
member like that and uh thank you that's
all I have to add I'll take any
questions thank you for your testimony
are there questions for this Witness
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
only two cards left
uh next up we have Sebastian Fuentes
he is speaking it briefly in support of
the Bill signed up for one minute and I
I'm not sure what your organization is
so if you could just
absolutely thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee my
name is Sebastian Fuentes and I'm the
movement politics director for rights
and democracy of New Hampshire but uh I
do want to testify initially as we made
a written testimony to the committee but
uh after hearing the comments from the
gentleman from the Independent Business
Association about the mania's key areas
he doesn't recollect the fact that many
skewers pay less than 15 an hour uh I
worked for 20 years at the bretonwood
ski area up in the North Country so I
can tell you for a fact that that's
wrong that information was wrong uh you
know I I flip bets I I you know run ski
lifts I serve tables I bus tables I
clean I clean dishes I did all that
stuff and I know currently at this point
there's people working at those
businesses they're actually making less
of 15 an hour uh and they're actually
some places that for example they
catering businesses they charge 30 of
the initial bill and they keep it they
keep the money for the property the
hotel keeps the money and they offer the
servers to get paid a flat wage of like
16 15 an hour so they make that money so
I can tell you for a fact that that's
the information is wrong uh and I'm here
to you know to express my support for HP
for this bill uh because I think it's
important it's important that we we do
we do this it's the right thing it's the
moral thing and I hope you uh agree with
me on that and that's all I do want to
say
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any questions
uh last up uh we told the prime sponsor
representative Schultz that she could
save her testimony for the end and she's
not sure how long she's going to speak
but
I'm sure she is mindful that we're
running a little bit behind and
we'll
speak for allowing me to do this Mr
chair I am representative Schultz from
Concord you're sitting in my district
yay
um I wanted to speak last because I love
having the conversation around the myths
and to address some of the questions but
before I get to that I just want to
briefly say when we're talking about
work when we're talking about Labor and
the people who hold them it oftentimes
it can seem like people on a spreadsheet
looking at numbers that maybe your
Investments get stuff like that but to
me as the daughter of a receptionist and
a baggage handler
and they were the children of a Bourbon
maker and a paramutual clerk at the
racetrack good union jobs
um I know that not everybody wants to be
an entrepreneur not everyone wants to go
to or could go to college
we need all of the jobs that are filled
are trying to be filled and the notion
that all labor has dignity matters to me
and what is amazing to me about this
conversation
is one aspect of what is traditionally
Republican thinking seems to have just
disappeared in the granite state the
notion of personal responsibility the
notion of pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps the notion of rugged
individualism
but if you are making a low wage and
maybe would like to start a business
whatever it is completely impossible I
hope that if you take anything away from
this conversation I feel like most of us
arrived with obviously I support the
bill I feel like these conversations
start in a way where everybody's already
made up their mind everybody in the room
I would like to invite everyone in some
Forum I'm probably too low on the totem
pole to host this with Business Leaders
with workers with legislators or a
robust discussion about Labor and wages
and jobs in New Hampshire because there
is a serious problem
and the notion that someone can pull up
their bootstraps when they don't even
have shoes is something that really
matters the fact that all of the people
that the pastor and I used to work for
him uh Pastor Hopkins I know he meets
with many people who are at
um really Financial
a really difficult Crossroads and he is
right everyone that was coming in has a
job if you want personal responsibility
if you want people in America to do what
they're asked to do as a participant in
society an able-bodied person why would
you ever want Working Poor to be
something in our vocabulary in the
wealthiest Nation on Earth and one of
the wealthiest states in America the
wealthiest state to default to five to
to the federal minimum wage
is to me not even a moral issue it is
but also a broken capitalism and I'll
get to that in just a minute but I do
want to answer the a few points that
were raised obviously the restaurant
conversation will happen with the next
bill but representative Granger had
asked if tip wages were a part of this
it is and we'll get to that and I think
some folks answered that
um it was also raised that
uh going to the first step of 1350 would
be a I think you said a high 80 percent
jump
well okay
that is exactly what we can compare
ourselves to when we literally look at
the rest of New England why would we
want the race to the bottom again
Working Poor in capitalism makes no
sense
another person talked well we had a
great conversation about wage
compression
I would say
the truth of that is a rising tide
raises all boats
the worst argument to me against this
bill would be oh people who already make
a certain wage would be unhappy I don't
think they're who we should be pleasing
I'm glad they have that wage if we pay
everyone in the granite state
better than we are now and by the way I
think the point was made well by some of
our previous speakers that 15 is not a
living wage either it's too low in my
opinion this is a modest pill in that
sense
it is not a living wage
so again
um why would we have the cut the
category Working Poor in our in our
state
um I will skip like my 300 points I
could say
I'll save that for that robust
discussion I hope we can have
um just quick bullet points
Republican Rank and pile Granite State
voters
Republican Rank and filed voters in
America a majority want a better minimum
wage period and all of the questions
around the economics of how it is here
compared to other places we've had now
so many places so many other states
raise the minimum wage so many cities we
have plenty of data to compare it to and
the notion I I will say I agree with um
Mr Burke on the point he was saying that
there is a lag in the economy at the
very beginning I actually that is what
the research shows at the very beginning
when you implement a raise in the
minimum wage but that very quickly
rebounds and when it rebounds we have a
all of that money
stays in the economy for the most part
everybody who makes those wages
I need to have that money to spend on
um I want to make sure address the other
point I'm also really happy that um the
Free State network was here I think
talking about the race to the bottom
um I do believe most of us in the
legislature believe in a
um
and want people to participate in
society and want to look at everyone for
the most part as
in just a general human sense that we
love our neighbors
um most free Staters are supporters of
rational self-interest and to support
themselves alone I don't think that's
mainstream I think what we want is and I
think another of my friends from the
business Community said this
most uh employers like their employees
because they're in front of them and
we're human beings and for the most part
we do want to have
um
we want our state to be a nice place to
live and everything about attracting and
keeping workers for the high end also is
going to require people to hold those
jobs all labor has dignity to do the
jobs that maybe you wouldn't do or I
wouldn't do so I would like to encourage
everyone that is a legislator and I do
this to talk to the people in your
District when you're pumping gas talk to
the clerk there when you're
I I pick a job seriously talk to people
in your District the majority of people
want this to happen and you know
um
in this proud Nation the wealthiest
country on Earth the beacon of light on
a hill the Ronald Reagan notion of
personal responsibility and rugged
individualism only works if we actually
create a scenario where everyone is
valued not in a non-profit handout sense
my parents never wanted a handout they
volunteered they wanted to be able to do
their jobs work for their employer it
wasn't the top priority in their lives
they wanted to live a life where they
left their work at their work they were
fine that people made money off of their
work because they liked their jobs and
the people they worked with we have lost
that as we've had a race to the bottom
and if we're going to keep and create a
good robust economy you can't let one
sector of that economy
need to go on Public Assistance or those
businesses
need to um well those businesses
essentially have a backdoor corporate
welfare where we're subsidizing the
wages of those employers you should want
every person who is working hard to do
the right thing to make a decent enough
wage where their work is valued and
their role in our economy is valued and
they don't need to seek assistance for
just the basics we should want our
economy and our capitalism to be
interdependent in that way and I I still
have four thousand other points but I'll
stop there
thank you uh are there questions yes sir
thank you Mr chair and thanks for uh
coming out here today uh so you
mentioned that uh you don't believe 15
an hour is enough uh do you support 50
as a minimum wage if that were a bill
that we were discussing today I'm sure
any worker would love to make fifty
dollars if they are making 15. I will
say this that does remind me of another
point the last time I was able to get
this statistic and I'll get the most
updated one was a year or two ago
uh over a hundred and forty four
thousand Granite Staters make under 15
an hour so I think to get to the heart
of your question I don't think they
expect fifty dollars I think they do
expect a wage that is reasonable enough
to pay rent
have food raise a family and live a life
that covers just the basics so while I
personally would love to see a much
higher wage that is closer to a living
wage so people could go on vacation save
for retirement pay off student loans you
know afford medical bills if they have
medical debt that is a whole other
conversation but I appreciate the
question and I don't think that is
needed for this bill
bow up
um so would you or would so if there was
a bill that said that we were raising
the minimum wage to fifty dollars would
you support it or would you oppose it
uh that sounds interesting I will say I
don't know how to answer that because I
don't see anyone filing a bill like that
um if that question is intended to show
something and who I am and the value of
this bill I I just
I'm not sure her I really genuinely just
not sure how to answer that I do
appreciate the conversation and I would
love to have that bigger conversation
and I would encourage folks to look at
the MIT living wage calculator
um because a basic living is really
crazy and if you are making ends meet
and you don't need to budget and
everything's cool it's hard to
understand what life is like in the
everyday world because or for people
making a low wage because it's it's
expensive to make low wages you're
you're making ends meet in a way that
becomes more expensive in a weird way it
it takes up too much of your time to go
to Pastor John's Church or other places
to seek assistance to avoid becoming
homeless to get out of homelessness
that's the reality that people are
facing so I like that there are better
paying jobs in New Hampshire I like that
there are a lot more small businesses
per capita than any other state in the
country but we would have more if people
were in a position to become more
entrepreneurial if they could just do
the basics in their lives and they
aren't
yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
um you mentioned that you had spoken
with some workers at a gas station and
um their support of a pay increase
do you remember the days of when we used
to have full service gas stations and we
had somebody pumping our gas for us I
will now admit I'm from Kentucky
originally
um I still occasionally go to one of the
gas stations in town that does that
um so I'm sorry to say while I'm married
into New Hampshire I don't have that
memory
I guess I don't remember I don't even
I'm sorry follow-up yes um
are there any gas stations around
anymore that have full service uh in in
New Hampshire that you're aware of yes
there's one at exit
16 off of I-93 right on the rotary to
the east
yes there are thank you and I believe
the owner is the person who
um traditionally is the person who pumps
the gas
foreign further questions yes
representative Davao
thank you thank you for taking my
question
we've had a lot of talk about the 15 an
hour
um my question is in January 2026 it's I
call it like a variable uh minimum wage
pretending we're sitting there in 2026
right now do you know what the minimum
wage would be
if you're if you're using this year's
consumer index is it more than 15 is it
less do you know what that number is
um I of course can't say none of us can
say unless someone has a time machine
and hasn't shared it I'd be sad about
that
um please share it uh of course we can't
know for sure what 2026 brings but I do
know on January 1st we heard about all
those States including every state
around us that had a raise in the
minimum wage and we also heard about
Social Security checks that are tied to
Cola had a raise I think that that value
of the dollar in New Hampshire I'm glad
you raised the inflation issue if you
can't afford it in a good year when the
economy is fantastic and prices for food
and gas Etc are average you're
struggling but not as much as you are
right now so to account for that is
important and that we haven't
had a cola attached to the minimum wage
at any level federal state Etc I think
is a real mistake
so I believe regardless of the answer to
your question I would still support a
cola well I think I actually asked my
question wrong sorry oh okay please
what I'm getting is say we are
basing our minimum wage pretend it's
your bill for 2026 and we're basing our
minimum wage off your new the new way
we're going to do it what would that
number be for this year with the
inflation do you know I don't know the
answer I'm just wondering if that was
over 15 as it is
or not I I don't know the I don't know
how to answer that question I do know if
we'd kept pace with the cost of living
from when the minimum wage was first
introduced it would definitely be above
15 in America
we have not kept pace with the cost of
living
the way it was meant to be it was meant
to be the floor for the basics and
people at that time when minimum wage
was created in America one parent could
have a job at say Sears or wherever and
they could
pay their mortgage get groceries
put clothes on their family all those
the basics
um and I believe that's the what the
floor of a minimum wage is supposed to
be about I'm sorry that I probably can't
answer your question I will say though
there is at the last part of the cola
section
it does have an adjustment that says
um it shall not
uh re result in a decrease so if there
are years where Social Security because
it's tied to the cola either way I
believe I'm not a social security
recipient it's there are years where it
goes down I believe I don't know for
sure but I wanted to make sure that the
cola never went in the negative
thank you I'm sorry that I know I
probably couldn't that was your question
the number was
I can get you more statistics on the
cost of living though compared to what
it would be now from what the minimum
wage was and what it would be today I'm
sorry I don't have that in front of me I
used to know that by heart each year if
you could do that that would be good
okay sure yeah
representative colquin question
oh yes have you um
spoken with your constituents or the
businesses in your area about the um why
there are so many full-service gas
stations and why we are now seeing so
many automated cash registers and less
and less people working at at um our
retail establishments
um so I see where you're going with your
question if we're able to automate some
of the jobs that we have that would
result in Less jobs being available I'm
not sure that that is a scarcity
necessarily people have faced
um sectors of the economy disappearing
are the whole lifespan of our country I
knew someone that made his many millions
because he
um had the cables did the cabling of
America for cable television
um now that there's Wireless
um
internet and TV
his business has gone under I'm pretty
sure
but um I think there are sectors of the
economy that shift and that's why we
have a number of um
I mean this is a growing economy there
will always be places where people could
shift I just feel like this bill is only
about the wage piece but when we talk
about the bigger conversation around the
economy and jobs I would love to talk
more about that
could we have one final follow final
follow-up
um I'm sorry my question was have you
spoken with your constituents on the
retail establishments about why they
have gone to an automated process
um that's an interesting no I haven't
spoken with anyone who has automated
their business per se
um but I do have those conversations
with
business owners and people in my
district who work at businesses all the
time in a subtle way in a non-nosy way I
usually just say so if I were to get a
job here what's the entry wage stuff
like that
but that's an interesting question that
I can't answer really
any further questions I have one uh just
requested the sponsor for information
there is uh there is a network of
support for people who are low-wage
workers
and it would be good if you could
provide some member of this group could
provide some information to us relative
to that support network
uh in the sense that low-wage workers
need a lot more help and so if you have
any information to support that to show
what it is that we are contributing now
uh because many workers a low wage would
be helpful to them yes and I think we
can also get some of that information
from companies like Walmart who do
instruct their employees how to go on
assistance I mean there are a number of
organizations that help people who are
working in poor I'd be happy to to get
that information thank you
and
all right thank you that concludes all
the cards we had submitted for this bill
we are a bit behind so I will
close the hearing for HB 57 and
immediately launch into the hearing for
HB 58 which is prohibiting payment of
sub minimum wages at this point I only
have two cards for it I expect to see a
couple more
um
no no we don't but
uh I'm sorry and uh
representative Schultz is again the
prime sponsor for this bill and you are
recognized to introduce your bill thank
you Mr chair and honorable labor
committee members I am still here
um
I'm glad we had a lot of the discussion
around tipped worker issues
um on the previous bill and I think all
of us sat through that so that's helpful
this bill would essentially eliminate
the sub minimum wage category especially
for tipped wage earners it does not get
away or eliminate tipping
uh tipping is it
something that workers have had access
to in certain jobs for centuries across
the world
what this does do is make sure that the
promise that all workers in restaurants
or other jobs that are tipped wage jobs
would actually get what they are
promised
which is a minimum wage we've had a
number of cases in this state that have
shown either through greed or confusion
probably more confusion and
misunderstanding than anything nefarious
where restaurant owners employers did
not pay their workers what they're
supposed to be paid
um I think that we can look to the 11
plus other states that have already
eliminated
the sub minimum wage category
um to see that it has not at all hurt
their economy
as a matter of fact
um the CEO of the corporation that
includes Denny's said on an investment
call that in the states at that point
especially California
actually their business was up
um and that it had he did not see any
um problem with it in that regard I
realized there will be folks that will
speak for the business community and say
otherwise but
um really the intent of this bill is to
eliminate the confusion and honestly
historically in America the notion of a
sub minimum wage started
um I hope this is helpful and not an eye
roll moment but it's true why we have
Subway sub minimum wages in America is a
Vestige of slavery after slavery ended
in America
first the people who were formerly
enslaved were in jobs that depended on
the um the Gratitude the tips of the
people they were serving so uh Pullman
car workers restaurant workers a number
of jobs that were in service to others
and so their entire wage was dependent
on
the graciousness of the customers and
that was by Design
you know people who had
um
people who were previously enslaved uh
wanted it that way they wanted it to be
something that
I hate to say it this way but it was
true what the white people
um were okay with for that worker and
that is horrible
um and in all those years what is it 150
years we've gone from zero for sub
minimum wage workers to in New Hampshire
three dollars and 27 cents an hour
in a logical sense it it just it
genuinely makes no sense I get that
that's what restaurant owners are used
to
um I get that it's sort of a part of our
culture most people don't know the
history of sub minimum wages but in
those states that have done this it has
not caused a problem for their economy
it's actually
ensured that workers are paid what
they're supposed to be paid which by the
way is what workers really just want and
tips on top is fantastic and for some
restaurants
servers bartenders even back of the
house us boys
um that was my first job as a my title
was busboy at a Chichi's restaurant on
Dixie Highway in Louisville but anyway
um
yes so for tipped wage workers all this
would essentially do and four of the
owners of restaurants and any other
establishment that has a tipped wage
category it would ensure that a minimum
wage is actually what is paid
um we again wouldn't be the first state
to do that so
um there were there is a segment of the
law and this is why there's an amendment
that went into some
if you want to call them carve outs or
exceptions
um my the original bill which actually
I'm I'd like but
um would have gotten rid of all those
categories
um
some who support this bill and I'm fine
with this I wanted to have that
discussion about those exceptions
possibly in another bill or just to
leave it alone and so that's what the
amendment does and I support the
amendment obviously I'm sponsoring it
and so it would only keep the passage of
um eliminating a sub minimum wage
category and leaves those exceptions for
the ski patrol so you can get your ski
pass for the season that sort of job
would be exempt
so I just wanted to make that clear that
this only simplifies the situation and
thank you for your testimony I do have a
question you have stated both today and
I've heard it before that you do not see
this bill or something similar as a
substitute for tip wages
I have heard other Advocates of this say
that that actually is their goal that
they
feel that tipped wages are unfair and
the attempt is to eliminate it
how do you respond to that
um that is another debate
um for another bill I personally think
that it would be cool so that folks
aren't dependent on because especially
now people are Moody me included you
know to depend on if someone likes that
you're wearing a mask or you're not
wearing like all the things that might
impact a tip I see the wisdom behind
just keeping it simple but that isn't in
this bill I'm fine with tips and tipping
and I don't want to mess with the tips
and tipping this is just about the base
bottom of the barrel wage
representative
I just want to get a clarification of
something and it relates to uh your
suggesting that people are not getting
the federal minimum wage in effect
everybody is required to get the federal
minimum wage in the case of New
Hampshire uh as I understand it and I'm
asking you for your interpretation of
this is it the only difference when you
have a tip wage is to the employer uses
the tips to offset their responsibility
to the federal minimum wage is that
correct I believe so thank you
and so this would just ensure that all
employers do it the same way by and
large
it simplifies law and again we have the
example of 11 other States including
such uh woke States like Utah and I
believe it's
um Minnesota there are multiple States
um
your point is well taken follow-up
question so if the employer if the tips
are not enough
to get the employee to 725 an hour is
the is the employer response be
responsible for the full 725 an hour
they are supposed to be
there some restaurants have good
guidance and I'm sure our lodging and
Restaurant Association helps with this
to explain how workers can be paid the
proper amount but to say the wage is
3.27 but you'll really make 7.25 an hour
is super confusing and we've had a
number of high profile cases in the
state from the U.S Department of Labor
saying these workers were not paid the
wage that they should be paid it's very
confusing and makes no sense but to your
point
who are the questions
seeing none thank you for your testing
oh I did want to say if you don't mind
Mr chair one more thing
um in the previous testimony Maine was
mentioned and that there were so many
servers that arrived to testify against
and want to repeal it
um we have surveyed New Hampshire
restaurant workers a majority of New
Hampshire tipped wage workers would like
to see this bill pass and as I
understand it
those restaurant workers by and large
were encouraged by their employer to go
or paid to go I believe
so while I get that people who are
making good money at an expensive
restaurant probably want to keep things
the way they are
we have to look at the entire industry
as a whole
so I I would say
I would take exception to the to any
argument that says this is what a
majority of restaurant workers in New
Hampshire would not want because that
simply is not the case I believe all
workers want to at least be paid the
minimum
thank you
next I would like to ask representative
McWilliams a co-sponsor of the Bill of
speaking in support uh signed up for two
thank you chair infantine for the record
my name is Rebecca McWilliams I am from
South Concord I represent
boards five six seven eight and you're
currently sitting in one of my Wards so
welcome to my district it's a pleasure
to host you
um I'm here to testify on behalf of
removing the sub minimum wage altogether
we've heard all kinds of discussion with
the previous Bill and this bill about
how it seems as though the industry is
changing at least in other states and
there's an opportunity here to even
things out I know that the tipped wage
is quite a discussion
and I'm trying to skirt around that and
not get into restaurants and tipped wage
I really want to talk about some of the
other folks who fall under these
exceptions folks who are seasonal
workers high schoolers folks in training
for different labor positions I think
that at this point the pendulum has
swung so far back the economy has moved
forward and we're stuck at the federal
minimum wage you know we've all
talked about how you can't live on it
you know it's it's barely enough to
maybe maybe buy a coffee once a week if
you feel like you're springing but
you're not gonna be able to pay rent at
the minimum wage but nonetheless we have
folks who are new to the workforce or
it's their first job and they do deserve
the Dignity of at least the federal
minimum wage and so I'm here just to
testify and say that for
for too long we have allowed it to be
three quarters or half of the federal
minimum wage for some of these
exceptions and I'd like to see that go
away and be fair and at least try to
base it on the federal minimum wage only
without exemption
happy to take questions thank you are
the questions
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony thank you
um next I would call back Henry vayu
he is speaking in opposition to the bill
and represents an hlra
thank you Mr chairman again uh I'm Henry
beyou on behalf of the New Hampshire
logic and Restaurant Association and we
oppose this bill this one is is
quite a dramatic change we've seen bills
to adjust the tip wage but this one does
away with it all together and would
fundamentally change uh the economics
and that the business model uh for
restaurants
um and so we oppose it
um again tip workers are the the highest
wage earners in the industry
um we don't see the need for something
like this
um and as I mentioned in Maine uh they
reversed uh what they did there
um I spoke with
um one of the
mid-sized restaurant operators yesterday
and he kind of shared some of his
numbers he said his current cost for
servers is and he has locations around
the state is 1.4 million dollars and
under this bill
that cost would increase to 3.4 million
and with the margins in the industry the
way they are you can't absorb all of
that and it would reflect in menu prices
and menu prices would have to go up
quite a bit so that would be the effect
of it
um
and so we would oppose this I'm happy to
answer questions I know we're coming up
on noon time thank you I see lots of
questions uh representative Brewery
thank you Mr chairman um
you made a statement that right now it's
costing say a million dollars to someone
and it's going to go to 3 million
but you also said that the highest paid
people so if they're getting way more
than minimum wage
where does that extra two million
dollars uh fit in here it seems like
they're already making that much well uh
the cash wage from the employer right
now is 327. so if you now require them
to pay the full minimum uh
that's that's more than double uh what
the current uh
well look at least
but they're really obligated to pay this
the 7.25 and it's going to go to 13.50
so you're only talking about that window
of increase
but the way you projected these people
making so much more than minimum wage
they're already making 15 or 20 dollars
an hour
yeah I was trying to uh explain from the
operator's standpoint the cost right now
for the servers
which is the 327 an hour
and the difference
um
under this bill which would do away with
that 327 it would then say you have to
pay the servers
well and under now would be 725
so it's a difference between the 327
in the 725 which is more than double or
60 percent of his staff
yes the from the employee side they're
making that correct but from the
employer's side
representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I think we've heard uh in testimony
in the previous Bill one thing that
could happen in response to this
changing of how restaurant compensation
is structured is that a restaurant could
choose to raise menu prices and prohibit
tipping altogether
have you seen any other arrangements um
that would either be legal in the New
Hampshire law or common in other states
such as tip pooling or anything else
that you would could would think that
might be a response uh to this bill and
how to restructure how both front of
house and backup house are are
compensated
yeah uh so tip pooling tip sharing
that's
um it's a tricky issue
I know uh the department uh the New
Hampshire Department of Labor
um play pays close attention to tip
pooling and tip sharing again tips are
the property of the employee
and you can't you certainly can't share
the tips from the people in front of the
house or the back of the house
uh or you you uh yeah you can't do it
um to the property of the employee and
any tip pooling and tip sharing
Arrangement has to be voluntary and uh
so no one can be required to participate
in one of those uh tip pooling tip
sharing arrangements and there are
employers that do get fined uh because
the department thinks the way they run
theirs
that crosses that line and so employers
have to be very careful with regards to
uh tips because they are the property
the employee
hold on follow-up
um
do you know if that's currently New
Hampshire law or federal law that
prohibits to pulling from front of house
tobacco house and do you think if it's
New Hampshire law there would be a push
to change that if the front of house and
back of the house would make the same
state law yeah
and second half do you think there would
be a push to change it if this went in
this was passed
um
I don't know that the proponents of this
bill would push for that but I suspect
maybe the industry would I don't know
um
is making such a dramatic change like
this will probably result in other
things happening exactly I think it's
what you're trying to to point out is
that they're going to be
representative McKenzie
uh
this is not gonna be easy in a pack but
let me I have some questions relative to
your to your numbers that you that you
came up with suggesting that this is
going to be a major increase for
employers
currently they pay 7.25 an hour
um in the house whoever
they have to meet that standard correct
so
a restaurant operator to the tipped
employees
they give them the cash wage of 327 an
hour yes the rest comes in tips
so if you were to pass this bill instead
of 327 an hour it would be 7.25 an hour
to all the service which represent and
this place was 60 percent of the the
staff
uh follow-up question so what is
occurring is it uh some two million
dollars I think would you suggested that
is actually the tips of the customers uh
that are going to offset the employer's
responsibility is that correct so it's a
minimum wage so I think you're trying to
like color the wages uh when I say color
the tips are red and the the the cash
wage for the employer is blue and
somehow you know the the worker gets
some red dollars and blue dollars at the
end of the day I think the tip workers
like it the way it is because it's
whether it's tips or from the employer
they're still the highest paid
I don't know if I answer your question
no no
we could talk afterwards I think this is
an important Point Mr Mr chairman
that that uh that the wages the tipped
the tips that employees receive
go to offset the employer's
responsibility towards the minimum wage
is that correct uh you weren't
recognized for a follow-up on just to
remind everyone we all have
the executive session to make our
important points about these bills and
uh I appreciate that you you've had some
good questions but we we don't need to
engage Witnesses in a debate
thank you if you if you have a follow-up
you are recognized for it
I okay I'll repeat my question
so
um the minimum wage is 7.25. and I think
what you're trying to say is that the
employer
because they're only paying the cash
wage of 327 they use the tips to offset
the 725 minimum that uh is re they're
required to pay either and uh yes thank
you
um
I'll go around this way and then come
back representative
I I wanted to go around this in the
whole room man
thank you Mr chairman thank you rep uh
Mr vayu for being here for us
um
the difference between the tip wage and
a 725
is we pay the taxes and insurance and
everything else that accumulates for
that 327 to be paid to the employee if
we were now required to pay 7.25 we
would have to do a obviously a match of
withholdings
workman's compensation uh possible
increase in other insurance areas
whether it be short-term disability
long-term disability things like that
um so I think that the
way it has been interpreted as that tips
offset those wages but the employer is
responsible for paying the initial cost
for those wages which in your example
would increase the cost the base cost of
the employer exactly thank you thank you
Mr chairman
other questions
representative Mason thank you for
taking my question thank you
um could you tell me do you know of
other states that
go to a minimum wage or that they all
have a reduced wage for restaurant
workers uh the majority of states the
overwhelming majority uh I have a
minimum and for servers there's a
could I follow oh yes so
I'm struggling a little bit with this I
mean I just
shake it on an airplane and you fly
somewhere
I mean
the POS systems today
they have recommended tips and this and
that so if you had special
something different where the wages of
it would have created a problem where
people just wouldn't know how much to
tip
if the wages were added to their food
prices
uh well I mean that would no I think
people would well what would be the
result of uh this bill
uh requiring the full minimum to the
servers uh
menu prices would increase dramatically
and what would be the result of that
um
you know it'll probably would be mixed
maybe there would be some that would
still continue to tip at the same level
there'd probably be some low-wage
workers that now the price of the meal
increase so much they can't tip as much
um
maybe some people wouldn't go out as
much because they can
um so it would have a variety of effect
yeah
thank you
any further questions
yes
thank you Mr chair I do tip so generally
do tipped workers work harder or do they
is that just a general State uh they
they look tip workers are the most
valued uh workers in the industry
because they're the face of the and
they're they're interacting with the
customers uh uh they work hard they're
valued and that's probably why they're
the highest pain
thank you
any further questions representative
proud
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
the other member's question about the
point of sales is another display a
recommended tip made me think of
something would you knows whether it be
anything in existing law that prohibits
uh restaurants for example from charging
a 10 service fee and then also
recommending a tip of 10 using that
service fee to make up the difference in
the uh new higher minimum wage they have
to pay and acknowledging that in
recommending a lower tip and using that
thank you
I'm not I I don't know that I can answer
that okay yeah
any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
um next up I would like a representative
Staub
who is a co-sponsor of this bill
obviously in support and has asked for
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee
um uh I hadn't planned to speak but let
me just say that I've been and doing a
little bit of research while folks have
been talking the tipped wage in Maine is
6.90 would be which is
um just 35 cents less than what what
this bill would would do and in
Massachusetts it's 8.25 cents and in
Vermont it's 6.59 and in New Hampshire
it's 3.27
also I would like to expand the um
um scope Beyond restaurant workers
hairdressers are also
tipped workers they get paid 3.27 cents
an hour a number of years ago I spoke to
an elderly woman who lived in Kittery
Maine and she was in her 80s but she
still liked it to work as a hairdresser
and they would call her in to one of
these chain hairdressing salons so she
said yeah and when I get called to work
in Portsmouth if nobody comes in they
pay me 7.25 cents an hour this was a
number of years ago she says but if I
get to work in Maine I get paid nine
dollars an hour so um you know if nobody
comes in then you get paid the the
minimum wage I think the other thing
which I'm not 100 sure about but
um I would invite you to investigate
this is I believe you can
um
um average so for example if someone
comes in and has a really good shift and
they make you know thirty dollars an
hour for their shift and they come in
the following day and nobody's there and
they spend it
rolling silverware or you know sweeping
the floor in the bathroom or you know
doing little menial tasks
um and and they don't make any money
nobody comes in then you can average
over those two days so they don't have
to pay the the 7.25 cents an hour for
that day of work
um
so I just you know I just wanted to take
the opportunity to answer some questions
there are eight states that um do not
have a sub minimum wage for restaurant
workers and their California Minnesota
Montana Nevada Oregon Washington and
Alaska
oh and one more I
but there are a number of states that
are on track to get rid of the tipped
minimum wage as well
thank you very much are there questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next I would ask Stephen nass from the
Free State Food Network who was speaking
in opposition for the bill
signed up for one minute
thank you I'll be very brief um I've
already stated that I believe that
workers in the state would not support
this bill and I find it really odd uh
that somehow I've made it through my
whole career without working with
servers that want to do away with
tipping but I did want to bring up uh
somebody uh
a previous speaker made some points
about uh businesses like Denny's and
they might have mentioned some other
ones uh
finding it more profitable to do away
with tipping in the states where they
they were forced to do away with tipping
and uh I would just like to make the
point uh that
these big corporations like this would
not be in favor of voluntarily getting
rid of tipping or they would already do
it but they are in favor of the playing
field for everybody being leveled like
that because they can as massive
franchises can more easily absorb those
costs versus their competitors the small
businesses which a previous speaker
spoke about they love the fact that New
Hampshire has many small businesses and
we're really thriving in that way
compared to some other states
these big corporations would love for a
bill like this to take place so that a
huge burden is placed on themselves but
also all of their competitors and their
competitors would be unable to absorb it
so we would see in our state uh what
would happen would be like what happened
with Walmart and all their competitors
were Walmart can drastically drop their
prices their competitors go out of
business Walmart takes that market share
and take takes over and then now you
don't have any competitors anymore I
don't think I personally want to live in
a state where uh we drive all of our
small businesses under and then we're
just left with the Denny's the
Applebee's the TGI Fridays Etc I'd much
rather uh keep the tipped wage which
allows the small businesses to be
competitive with the larger corporations
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
representative Sullivan
thank you for taking my question was was
it your understanding that this bill
does away with tips
uh well it it dramatically affects it
does it not uh it's we're discussing the
payment of sub minimum wages so any
anything that's uh removing the ability
and interfering with the ability of
small businesses to decide their own
wages uh is going to have that effect of
making them anti-competitive
oh
is it your understanding that this bill
does away with tipping
uh that is not my understanding thank
you
any further questions
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
um I'm down to two cards
and so representative baroody if you
could get the um blue sheets for 57 and
58 and pass them forward while we wrap
things up here I would call
Representative Horrigan who is
uh
uh speaking in support of the bill for
two minutes
I was glad the uh I'm president Timothy
Horrigan for Stratford County District
10 which is the town of Durham
um and we do have a number of
independent restaurants in town
um I I I would uh I would disagree that
this I've read the previous uh witness
acknowledged that it doesn't eliminate
tipping um there's
um I think there is still a you're still
a little tip it's just the uh lower just
like the floor that's guaranteed by the
employer would be hired I don't think
that would uh drastically drastically
increased menu prices and I'm not even
sure increasing many prices is that
terrible the catastrophe and if
if indeed the servers are the highest
paid people in the restaurant business
because they're the public-facing side
of it
um that would make that industry
somewhat unique that's not how most uh
Industries in our capitalist Society
work usually the people at the front
lines are the the lowest paid
and um
the previous windows also mentioned
Walmart and earlier today we heard about
uh about Sears once Sears was a a
Goliath that dominated the retail
Industries I'm sure
Walmart will eventually go the way of a
way of Sears and other retail goliaths
maybe somebody else will take its place
so it
okay thank you well while Mart was
mentioned in this bill so that's um
and actually the another point which I
haven't been mostly hearing but it's
probably hasn't been taken up much is uh
sub minimum wages for example with
people with disabilities I
I think um I think those
uh they're if they if they're not worth
the minimum wage I can understand why
you have them coming in and doing tasks
but they should not be asked to
subsidize their jobs that should be done
by uh someone else and they should be
guaranteed the minimum wage for their uh
for their efforts so
I urge you to uh
okay I've heard that while I was already
fixed so there's an amendment coming in
so that's but
I urge you to support this bill um and
higher wages are not a bad thing anyway
so thanks
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you again uh last up
and if I get this wrong again I'm sorry
okay thank you maybe I'll remember it if
next time
to throw people off aftc in support of
the bill two minutes yes so thank you so
much I wasn't originally intending to
testify but I just wanted to share
another story so I appreciate your
Indulgence and your time um in hearing
me today uh so the first restaurant job
I ever had in New Hampshire was a little
place called new dad hang restaurant it
was a Chinese restaurant that was owned
by a Chinese couple that had come to the
United States because of the one child
policy Rule and so in order to keep
their youngest daughter they moved here
they picked up their whole family and
they moved here and raised their family
their children here and they opened the
restaurant in Goffstown in Pinardville
that was a local favorite and they hired
me at 16 years old with no experience in
restaurants I'd been doing mostly child
care and nannying at that point they
hired me and they started me off this is
I was 16 years old I graduated in 2005
that was 2003 I want to say they started
me off at seven dollars an hour and they
increased my wage progressively up to
ten dollars an hour and they continued
to allow me to take and earn tips on top
of that base wage and so I am in support
of this bill because if an immigrant
couple owning a restaurant in this state
who have very little and are working on
the thin margins and I know they're not
the only example of restaurant owners
business owners who are in good you know
have a good relationship with their
employees are trying to do the best that
they can to provide their employees and
we were a small restaurant we were a
staff of four people two people in the
back of the house one per person that
was me who ran back and forth from the
front of the house to the back of the
house and our driver Fred who was great
and so if they could manage to pay me
and Fred and anyone else that they would
hire seasonally for the very very busy
periods at minimum ten dollars an hour
plus tips I think that there is no
reason why this committee and why this
state in the year of Our Lord
2023 cannot increase the base sub
minimum wage to be at the very minimum
to meet the federal standard it does not
do away with tips our tipped workers
would still be able to be able to earn
those tips that is not the issue
employers
across the state are willing to do this
and unfortunately they're not here and
that's good to know it's good for us to
recognize that we need to be bringing
more of those base those voices into
this space but my hope is that my story
recognizing that this is already
happening and we can do this so please
vote ought to pass on HB 57
thank you very much are there questions
seeing none thank you that was my last
card for this bill
so before I close the hearing we had a
number of people signed the blue sheets
for HB 57 the first one there were 19 in
favor and three opposed for HB 58 there
were 18 in favor and one opposed I would
remind both the committee and anyone
watching that we also now have online
signups and online testimony so
um that is open throughout the day so
that can keep coming in and that's
something that can be checked online
so with that I'll close the hearing for
HB 58 we are now into our lunch time uh
hopefully 40 minutes is plenty of time
for everybody and we can be back here
promptly at one to pick up on our next
hearing
any questions or comments before we
leave
ah yes
thank you everyone see you at one
o'clock
if everybody could head to their seats
we're a couple minutes behind but
representative Cahill having arrived we
so before before I start uh
representative Sullivan hopefully
um asked for a current printout of the
online remote testimony and sign-ins so
I would just like to for the two bills
that I read the blue sheets for
um HB 57 had 152 in support five opposed
had 79 in support and three opposed and
I will save the other ones until we get
to those bills
um with that I will open the public
hearing on
HB 48 which is relative to employee
protections from covid-19 in the
workplace and I would ask the prime
sponsor representative Horrigan
to introduce his Bill thank you thank
you very much and um I'm I was supposed
to be in three places at one time at one
but um my own committee is running half
an hour behind education is running
about 15 minutes behind so
you're pretty much on time so hopefully
it'll all work out
um how many is there is it just the one
pink card aside from mine are there
others
sorry right now I have two pink cards
okay
all right cool anyway so it's uh
um it's a
pretty simple bill you actually except
for the effective date is identical to
what you had last year and that one
there were a lot of anti-vax bills and
this is sort of a flip side of it so
it's pretty much
it's pretty much silver 19 the right to
use personal protective equipment such
as face Shields and face masks while
employed in the workplace no employers
shall discriminate in any way against
employee based on you know the employee
exercising his or her rights um
and my intention would also
and I don't know if this covers it or
not but also be to forbid you know
discrimination and hiring uh based on
somebody being uh being vaccinated I um
so your employer would not be able to
fire you to discriminate you in any way
if you choose to get vaccinated against
covid-19 and I'll say um
even though uh I'm not wearing a mask
and none of us are it's still very much
a concern the pandemic is still going um
a million people died in China just just
in the uh last month or two after
McCarthy that's because they changed
their approach to covet but um
and they also can't stop you wearing
ppes
um this is I think this disease is still
running rampant it's killed over 1.1
million Americans and that's uh
that's one of the greatest catastrophes
in in the history of our country in fact
I think it is the biggest in terms of uh
the gross number of people and
um they're actually and um there
actually has been a
excess number of deaths and those deaths
have been due to uh very specifically
the respiratory disease I.E covid-19 and
not to any other causes that have been
uh theorized for it
now I frankly
don't know of any New Hampshire
employees of outright banned vaccines in
the workplace I did see one
I did see one uh online ad
um for I think it was like a business in
Manchester starting Casino which said
they're uh hosts and hostesses couldn't
be vaccinated but that's uh
but that could just be one isolated
incident but uh
I know during the 2021 shutdown and the
economic chaos that followed
a number of businesses uh shut down and
some of them did specifically cite to
ppes and the mass mandates just one of
the reasons why they shut down their
business so they did um
the probably other reasons why they
chose to shut down their business but a
number of business people did cite that
as a specific reason why they didn't
want to continue keeping the doors open
on their business so
and um so I've got several assumptions
here which
I think they're pretty widely accepting
the outside world but somewhere where
controvers here in the State House one
is I said the covid-19 pandemic is one
of the worst catastrophes in human
history and um it's still going on
um the vaccines I think they're well
worth taking they're not 100 effective
or 100 safe but they're they're very
effective and very safe
um specific especially the
three vaccines here and put down a
Pfizer and the chance of vaccine they're
all safe and effective they've been uh
they've been adequately tested the
process worked well in those cases um
and I actually followed that during the
pandemic I got to I
dear my free time that's what I did to
watch a lot of the webinars about it um
and I do think the vaccines they make
you less susceptible to covid-19 virus
and also less likely to spread it to
others um
also the ppe's are worthwhile even not
100 effective the same goes for the drug
treatments such as paxilovid which I
I'll say parenthetically actually cut uh
covid uh this summer and it was uh
obviously I didn't die but I did take
the Bachelor of it and that made a big
difference and finally this is very key
thing
there is no natural or Civil Right to
spread a deadly contagious respiratory
virus so that's um
you do have a I mean you have the right
to decide uh how you want to be treated
but you don't have the right to to
spread it to someone else so that's um
that's my bill I think it's a I think
it's fairly simple uh it fell a little
short last time but uh that was then
this is now and at the worst
and the worst uh at the worst you can
say that it's it's harmless but
um so I I would uh
and we should err on this side of
caution so we so be happy to take any
thank you
any questions for the representative yes
representative proud thank you Mr Urban
thank you representative my question
um how specifically regarding the um
right to use personal protective
equipment such as face mask and face
Shields while employing the workplace
how would you see this interact with um
any sort of regulations or workplace
requirements for like closed spaces and
other disadvantaged workplaces where
there are very specific requirements for
safety that may interfere with this
right
um and other working conditions where
that sort of issue would come up
um I don't know specifically if you feel
there's
if you feel there's an issue the bills
in your committee so you're free to uh
put an amendment to clarify that if you
want I think I mean
most of the time I can think of more
situations where you know like
especially like the medical industry or
let's see where you're required to mask
up even
in the absence of a coveted pandemic and
or wear face Shields I think this is a
I don't know Industries where
those common uh commonly used items uh
interfere with other safety requirements
but if if there are some um if there are
some then maybe the bill needs to be to
be tweaked because I certainly also
think it may need to be tweaked to
prevent discrimination at the hiring end
before you're working there because I
did see an example of that whether it's
isolated or not I don't necessarily know
but yeah so
if you want to mend a bill to adjust
that issue you're welcome to do so and
uh depending on whether I like the
amendment or not I'll support it or not
other questions yes representative thank
you Mr chair I've received a lot of
messages from people in my district as
well as others to amend the bill to
protect the unvaccinated as well would
you oppose a bill to ban uh if we
amended this bill to also include the
unvaccinated as protected from
discrimination would you support it or
would you oppose it well it depends on
the Texas bill but I probably uh
I would probably oppose that I mean
certainly we have the right not to get
vaccinated but that doesn't necessarily
mean that everybody else
has to pretend that it's
just as safe for that person they share
our the air that we breathe as it is
from somebody who's uh who's not
vaccinated and certainly the mass and
stuff then well very few people are
wearing them you see a few around the
state house but uh there's
um very few people who actually can't
wear them at all and certainly there
were exceptions to the rules for those
so I would I would probably
I'd probably be I don't haven't seen the
Amendments like I I can't I don't want
to speculate too much but I would guess
probably I probably I would not be in
too enthusiastic about it but I will
defer my final judgment until the
committee finishes at work and it comes
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative taking the question um
how do you Rectify this with workman's
compensation if the employee
it overheats on a hot day wearing
protective equipment
and falls and hurts themselves because
of the protective equipment with
workman's compensation cover them I uh
well
I'm not actually my workman compensation
we did have a
we did have two summers uh well when
people were commonly masking so like the
the pandemic hit the U.S and
well in Earnest in mid-march of 2020 so
the summer is the 21 and 22 were uh
where um
the counts numbers of 21 and 22 did
happen before we began getting back to
to the to normal or at least the new
normal so
um
I don't really know if large numbers of
people were overheating and stuff
certainly uh this is just uh I mean you
can wave the record I mean so we can
waive the requirement if uh if somebody
is uh is indeed overheating just from
wearing the mask or the face shield but
I don't really know that there are a
large number of of cases uh related to
that as I said we do have two summers
worth of data to uh
see whether or not that was the case
thanks follow up
thank you Mr chairman thank you for the
follow-up representative
type of employment that could catch
themselves on fire
whether it be a welder whether it be
somebody cooking in the kitchen whether
it be somebody outside
doing dangerous work
decides to wear a mask
well there's typically wear masks anyway
so uh they wear protective face shields
for their thing but if they have a mask
underneath and they you know gets out of
their mask and catches their thing on
fire with working with compensation
cover for that well once again
um
once again we although obviously the
hospitality issues you hit hard but
kitchens we do have two years of of data
on the incidents in kitchens and Wells
and other workplaces where they work
with flammable materials so um certainly
there are fireproof ppes you can and
other social filters that people have
been using routinely for years so
um
once again uh once again I guess I'm not
I'm not the not the expert on it but I'm
sure the information could be available
somewhere and certainly there are there
are fireproof PPE so like they're not
all
let's go it's not just a cheap k95 and
paper mask which I agree probably are
pretty flammable but there's other
there's alternative other alternative
devices people can wear and certainly
those Industries kept going during the
pandemic so there's probably some
experience with that
any other questions yes
McKenzie thank you uh
so I'm
I'm trying to understand this so what
what the what the in terms of the covet
vaccine so a healthcare worker a
paramedic A Firefighter all those people
can make a decision whether they want to
be vaccinated or not yeah and so the
employer why does the employer have have
access to that information one way or
the other that's a very that's a very
valid question I mean on the other side
that certainly our employers who've
asked their employees to be vaccinated
and I know
at the hearings last year for the
anti-vaxx Mills there were a number of
people who came in and told us that they
had quit their jobs rather than get
vaccinated after being asked to be
vaccinated or
or otherwise so that's uh
I mean most cases the employer doesn't
know for sure but they uh I mean it's
pretty easy to get vaccinated and not
tell your employer if your employer had
such a Prohibition in place and uh
I do know I do know anecdotally when I
went for the vax
you know we had the vaccine clinic
um March 20 2021 I know at least one of
our colleagues came who's
one of the most vocal anti-vaxxers and
uh he he came in and got the J J shot
just like uh
other members of us who are expressing
different positions so I mean that's uh
I don't want to say anything more about
it than that because that's his decision
and I understand why he made it and then
I understand why he's made the decisions
he's made since then but you know it is
true if your employer bends it it's
pretty hard for them to find out so but
still this would prohibit them from
harassing you if they don't like the
vaccine and found out that you got faxed
you have a follow-up I don't think so no
thank you any other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
the
final card that I have is Melissa blasek
uh representing rebuild New Hampshire uh
requesting three minutes and has not
signed up either in support or
opposition
aye thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Melissa blasik I'm the
executive director of rebuild NH and uh
we are neither supporting nor opposing
this bill as written we do oppose all
discrimination against anybody who would
choose to get a vaccine or not or wear a
mask or not
um
unfortunately the bill as written is
only one side of that coin and I find it
a little difficult to believe that it is
a widespread issue considering that for
two to three years there have been
government mandates for the vaccines and
masks and
I somewhat find it hard to believe that
people could be facing widespread
discrimination for simply following
government dictates however and I do
find it um
a little offensive to uh the countless
people who did lose their livelihoods
for their choice to not get a very
non-sterilizing vaccine
um that actually is showing negative
efficacy at the moment
um so but
as written I feel that the bill is a
solution in search of a problem but we
would support amending the bill to
include
anti-discrimination for those who get a
vaccine do not get a vaccine wear a mask
or do not get a mask and that is
concludes my testimony
I see no question so thank you again
thank you uh representative Broody if
you could pass the blue sheet for uh
um
and I do have the online testimony for
that online 11 signed in in support 18
and up position and seven signed in with
yes
and on the paper sign-in sheet we had
so with that we've got about six more
minutes before we can open our next
hearing so the committee will be in
recess until 1 30. thank you
foreign
um
if anyone lost did a search of bills and
their paper is missing uh a printout got
passed around with some other testimony
foreign
um
pictures
foreign
benefits
[Music]
seats
I would like to open the public hearing
on House Bill 74 relative to an
employee's unused earned time and
representative Cahill if you would
introduce your bill
thank you Mr chairman uh I am
representative Michael Cahill from
Newmarket I represent the towns of
Newmarket and new Fields Rockingham 10.
and uh
we
ber has seen this bill a few times in
various iterations this is very similar
to the one that we talked about last
year so but for the benefit of the new
members I certainly want to talk about
it again and and perhaps reinforce the
with this legislation I hope to prevent
the loss of ironed but unused time that
is and that this be recognized as wages
do when employment ends under certain
conditions these would include the sale
of the company where the time would be
transferred to the new owner or wages
paid by the prior owner now this is
something that is very commonplace but
apparently not required in the state of
New Hampshire when the company ceases
operations again this is something where
the employee had no control perhaps very
little notice and
you would pay the wages that they had
for the previous week or pre-pray period
but not the vacation wages that that was
not your policy again people have earned
these wages earned the vacation or a
layoff often happens without notice uh
one of the examples I've included in the
packet is a person who was laid off uh
on a Friday and the uh
file the claim with the apartment with
the labor department
but the the
the policy of the employer was that you
had to request your vacation time three
weeks in advance and with being laid off
with no notice you'd have no opportunity
to to request three weeks in advance so
this in fact is another situation where
the person lost I think it was on twenty
three hundred dollars which is
significant uh really through no fault
to their own and these wages would be
paid if this bill was were to pass going
forward so
uh the fourth one is when the employee
leaves in good standing given proper
notice Etc this is something that uh was
given to me by our The Honorable uh
representative
personal annuities who served on this
committee and had experience in human
resources and this is something where I
know people had said well what if I
catch the person stealing or they punch
the boss in the nose and this is really
what what if that doesn't happen what if
you had somebody who worked in your
company contributed and now this is just
the time for them to move on various
reasons and they uh perhaps they'll even
spend a little time helping train the
replacement
this could be this could be worth
something to you and you know earlier we
heard testimony that businesses like
their employees and I'd like to think
that's true and so why would you deny
them something that they've earned
simply because you can
so uh current law is Guided by the
employer's practice or policy which may
include this blanket statement vacation
slash PTO is not paid upon termination I
bring this legislation because
circumstances matter and when they are
beyond the employee's control they
should not lose what they have earned I
have cited the case where several
employees lost their earned time when
the business was sold the employer's
policy stated it is not paid on
termination and they made no provision
for their hours to be transferred to the
new company where they continue to work
in another case an employee lost three
weeks when laid off without notice the
employer's policy required two weeks of
dance notice when requesting time off
which was impossible under the
circumstance I want to point out the uh
Pines of New Market
documents when the
a nice given a separate sheet listing
the the the dollars that were claimed
attempted to claim that were accrued
vacation uh by five employees who did
file and lost because the employer's
policy said we don't pay out doesn't
matter that you've earned it and that
employer simply kept the
2261.44
that should have been paid to those five
workers
sorry I digress
um
right so uh of the applicable conditions
listed above only the only the last is
controversial in that the employee has a
role in the decision consider the
vacation that vacation requests are
approved by management and that the
needs of the business the ability to
cover the task Etc may not align with
the employee's plans
it may be in the best interest of the
company for the departing employee to be
at work the entire month the entire last
month rather than taking two weeks off
rather than lose them then giving notice
this would be to be particularly helpful
if the new hire would benefit from the
experience of the outgoing employee
during the transition
so is this a problem for the legislature
to solve some may say the policy was in
the employee handbook it's a contract
well yes this allows the employee to
plan the vacations and comply with any
user to lose it and carryovers in the
handbook these Provisions are unaffected
by the legislation it is primarily
addressing the events the employee could
not plan for like when Lucy moves the
football
so I have data a link here to the data
from the labor Department's ways
decisions and again not every claim not
every call or claim is logged only those
that go to a hearing were both parties
attend
so the numbers are probably a bit larger
than what I report here but I did give
you some numbers and that this is
and when people when people don't have
their vacation pay at the end if they go
to collect unemployment uh
they started immediately whereas if they
paid their vacation that those times is
used up before any any funds come from
the trust fund so if you have a week's
vacation paid to you your your claim
begins after that is used up so we
protect the trust fund we honor the work
of our employees and our commitment and
it's a it's a value that we should be
doing this
so
with that I will end and take any
questions thank you very much are there
questions
I don't see any questions so thank you
for your testimony may I add one more
thing yes you may thank you Mr chair I
did notice Mr arlinghaus and I think
he's going to speak to the fiscal note
which does seem like a large figure but
I believe that refers to a mass Exodus
of state employees which we will not
happen I know we're not we're not famous
for paying high wages but I don't think
everyone's going to quit at once
okay thank you
with that introduction I I would ask
commissioner arlinghaus
of the Department of administrative
services to speak he has checked off
that he's in support of the bill and I'm
a little concerned it looks like you
said you're going to speak for an hour
and an hour and a half uh a minute and
30 seconds okay good
um uh I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of administrative Services
I to be clear I'm neither in supporter
or in opposition to the Bill I'm here to
explain our fiscal note
um
so the fiscal note was written uh by
somebody saying what's the maximum
possible impact of this and and the the
number is extraordinarily large based on
who doesn't accrue leave in our current
system and I can explain that if state
government shut down entirely and
everybody were laid off these are the
people who don't accrue leave I think
that eventuality is unlikely State
government's very unlikely to shut down
and 11 000 people get laid off I'm not
aware of any plans in that direction and
they would concern me
um but it it outlines who the people are
and they're about they're about 830
people who don't accrue leave they fall
into two buckets
um they don't accrue leaving the system
one of them I'm going to actually
dismiss from the fiscal note immediately
which is judicial branch employees
because they track their leads
separately judicial branch employees do
get paid out leave upon Exodus upon
retirement or dismissal resignation or
dismissal and so 570 or so of those
people
um you should ignore from your fiscal
which would lower it the fiscal note
then refers to about 259 260
unclassified employees and and because
of the way the bill is written we don't
know if it applies to them or doesn't
apply to them from this standpoint
classified employees in the state system
accrue leave the leave is is banked and
managed and tracked in New Hampshire
first the state computer system and upon
their uh leaving in the system they do
get paid out for annual time that's on
the books and whether they're laid off
whether they resign or whatever the
circumstances are unclassified employees
do not they don't accrue leave their
leave is not managed in that way upon
their leaving the system there is a
there is a payout in lieu of that of
three days per year worked
and so regardless of regardless of what
happened so that the leave is not
tracked in that way if that payout is
sufficient for the meaning of the bill
um then there's no fiscal no whatsoever
if it's not sufficient for the meaning
of the bill the cost because I want to
exclude the judicial employees is about
um a third of the number that's in your
fiscal note and in addition to that it's
worth noting that that is a thought
exercise about what is the maximum
possible liability
and the unlikely event the state
government were to end which is not
probably something you want to use for
your purposes I think for your planning
purposes the fiscal impact on this is on
thank you for that testimony I do have a
question
um so given the situation where you have
a payout but it's not
let's say it's considered to not be in
compliant with this bill would that then
um in your mind make it a priority
given this effect to say well we need to
change the way remove the the payout
that we have and replace it with
something that matches the language it's
possible for the 259 people we would
have to do that for the unclassified
employees I don't
if I'm honest I think that I think what
would probably happen and and lawyers
would decide that's not me is we would
argue that that system is compliant with
the bill and I think I think my quick
read of the bill is that that's an
argument that could go either way and so
that that's what I would argue first if
it were found to be that case we would
merely have to have to tweak the way we
um account for unclassified employees I
don't think it would have any dramatic
effect on state government
thank you my pleasure any other question
uh yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
commissionerlinghaus
fiscal note with this did you include
any County or local
we didn't I don't we don't really have
any way to um to account for that we
don't we don't have the data or the
records to know the impact on County and
local thank you thank you
any further questions
thank you very much for a testimony
thanks have a great day
um next up I'd like to ask Dave Juve he
is representing the Bia he is in
opposition to the bill and there's a
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
David Juve I'm a senior vice president
for public policy with the business and
industry Association
we are opposed to the bill but it's a
issue that I have had frequent
conversations with representative Cahill
about and I promised him today I would
say something nice about it and the nice
thing I will say is there is a germ of a
fair idea in here that I want the
committee to recognize and that is there
may be situations
in employment where an individual is
laid off with no notification whatsoever
and if they are working for an employer
who doesn't pay for earned but unused
time
they lose that benefit and so I think
the germ of the fair idea would be if
you were to limit this
to employees
who had no control over there leaving
the company through a layoff
or even if the company were sold and
there were not arrangements for that
vacation to carry over to be paid off
that's something that I think you could
legitimately say that's not fair and I
think we would acknowledge that's not
fair
but for us this bill is too broad and it
creates problems the first is a
philosophical one which you may or may
not share with the Bia the philosophy is
employers are in the best position to
determine what benefits they want to
offer to retain employees and attract
new employees
but there are other issues with the bill
one of which is
it talks about the accrued time being
paid when the employee leaves in good
standing or the termination as a result
of a layoff
but there are a lot of companies out
there I work for one of them that have a
use it or lose it benefit so I get a
certain amount of days per year uh paid
time off vacation time if I don't use
that by the end of the year it's gone
and we start afresh January 1st this
doesn't seem to take that into account
so I don't know if that was by Design
meaning
that's too bad for those employees but
they didn't use it so they lose it or if
it was somehow
thought that they should receive that
but it wasn't written in the bill
the second is
there are companies again I'll use my
own employer as an example that we have
vacation time paid time as a benefit but
we also have something else that's
called personal time which is also a
paid benefit it's not meant to be used
for vacations it could be used for sick
but it's not called sick time
or sick days it could be used if you
have a sick child or a sick pet or in my
case I used it recently I was flying
home from Florida on Monday and my
flight was canceled and I couldn't get a
flight out until the next day on Tuesday
so the day I was planning on being at
work I was unable to
that's something that I would take a
personal day for not a vacation day so
and then there are companies and they're
becoming more and more common in the
technology economy that we're in
that don't have vacation days at all
they just were time off paid time off is
arranged between the individual and the
employer and it's not something that's
tracked so it's unclear how those
companies would make arrangements for
this so
all in all I think this bill has some
problems but if the committee would like
to refocus that on just employees who
are laid off terminated with no
knowledge and no ability to do anything
about that that's something I think we
could all consider thank you Mr chair
thank you for your testimony are there
questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um you focus on
uh with your fair idea the the employees
that are unable to use the vacation
because they didn't have a notice of the
of the termination of employment
um would you go as far as to extend that
to employees who are unable to use a
vacation because of the needs of the
business and they kept requesting
vacation time but they said but the
manager kept denying the request saying
that's not too good time this is too
busy and basically it snowballed
bringing them out snowballed in to make
you make it completely unable to be used
I um thank you for the question I think
it is certainly something worth having
some discussion about I'm not sure how
one
would track that or if it would be up to
the employee to show repeated requests
that were denied I I think your example
is a good one where it was not in the
employee's ability to take the vacation
I just don't know if there would be
difficulty tracking that or on the
employer's part
keeping track of of those requests I
think it's worthy of discussion
and follow follow-up so I think you
mostly already answered this but um
you you would foresee problems in
administering that sort of extension of
the idea
and determining who would qualify and
who wouldn't and the point where it
almost would be become unworkable
possible possibly I I could I mean you
you foresee problems in administering
that delineation between if the employee
was unable to use the time because of
the needs of the business or just
because they didn't use it
and determining from a departmental
labor standpoint which case is qualified
which didn't them not using it as fairly
black and white the being able to
distinguish a request that was turned
down the employer could say well that
particular week was not good
but the next week would have been
available but he didn't ask for that so
it's it's that type of situation that
that creates a gray area
thank you
yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Juve
good to see you again thank you
um
for the purpose of the layoff
we have seasonal obviously New Hampshire
has seasonal employees
do you see a problem with that if the
employee goes back to work a month later
after they're being laid off if you know
construction right behaving snow plowing
removal I mean any any industry that
only operates nine months out of the
year would lay off yeah for a temporary
layoff and then have them come back
would you see that being an issue
I think it's an excellent question and I
guess that is something I would my
answer would be the same that is
something that would be worthy of
discussion I don't know if if one
outcome would be they would be paid for
any accrued but unused time but then
when they start up again two months
later they start back at zero I I don't
know I think it's something that would
have to be discussed thank you thank you
I don't see any so thank you very much
for your test thank you
and let me see what's on the card
um
yes but I I think I'll go with this
first uh representative Perez
is going to speak four to five minutes
thank you again members of the committee
for allowing me to speak my name is
Maria Perez I'm a state representative
from District 43 in Milford I'm here to
speak and support of this bill because
it is critical
the people have the right to roll over
whatever specific time a personal time
they earn
in a lot of cases especially in some
Industries people don't have a coverage
to be able to use that time before the
end of the year
and if that person works so hard to earn
that time I believe that should that
they should have the right to roll over
that time for example
um
I'm just going to be a little personal
in this one my mother-in-law she was
my husband
before preview of that hitting you to
utilize the time that he he had
he's an electrician so he earns a lot of
personal time
but by the time at the end of the year
came
he still have time off that he can
utilize the following year to take his
mother for
chemo and radiation
but he wasn't allowed to roll over that
time
it was hard for us as a family to be
able to take my mother love
to chemo and radiation
without wasting time and not having any
more personal time but if we he were
allowed
his employee would allow him to roll
over that time
he was be able to you know be with his
mom and not me taking my personal time
or other relatives has to take a day off
from work without getting paid because
we didn't have someone to be with her
that's why I'm supporting this bill and
I that's why I think it's critical for
us to support employees
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
I see none so thank you again
uh next I would call Bruce Berkey
representing nfib New Hampshire
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee again Bruce sperkey with the
national Federation of Independent
Business here in New Hampshire
representing over 1400 small businesses
and I think my testimony can be somewhat
expedited given Mr juve's presentation
to you
ours is similar maybe a couple of tweaks
um certainly
um and and line four of the bill where
it has the threshold of 15 employees
um
I'm not sure what the right number is
but the concern would be once that is
put into statute that that number could
be lowered over time and that could have
an impact on many many very very small
businesses in the state of New Hampshire
and in those lines four five six I think
it's important that it's recognized that
if there is a written policy that a
business has
but somewhat of a contract between the
employer and the employee that there's a
true understanding between the two of
what rights each side has
and
um if that unearned time is delineated
is is explained within that policy at
and and says you can't take it with you
or you can take it with you I think
that's what should dictate
the policy for that employee it should
not be State Statute it should be that
relationship between the employer and
the employee and not having the state of
New Hampshire dictating what the policy
is
and and I think that Mr juvet also
brought up a very very good point on
line 17 where if the person leaves in
good standing that really emphasizes the
the concern that I just expressed in
terms of that relationship between the
employer employee if that person in good
standing makes the decision to leave
and the policy lays out that they cannot
take their
unused earned income or earned time with
them
then they don't get it and and so I
think that you know it has to be
carefully crafted
so that
it isn't the state just stepping in and
saying
Mr business owner
Mrs business owner this is the way you
have to do it
I think it there needs to be that
flexibility between the employer and the
employee especially especially for very
small businesses in the state
with that I'll conclude my remarks and
be happy to try and address any
questions you may have right thank you
all right represent McKenzie thank you
um
so what standing does a person have uh
you talk about the relationship between
employer employees that they they have a
contract they use uh an agreement so
yeah so what um what jurisdiction in the
labor department is here they might be
able to answer this but do they have
standing under the law to be able to
challenge that in a case where they have
an agreement that has been worked out uh
where they have you know clear
um understanding and the employer does
not abide by the uh by the document well
if there's a clear written policy
but you know between the employer and
the employee and that employer violates
that policy I would think they would you
know definitely be an opportunity to
contest that at the Department of Labor
um but I think that you know that needs
Mr chairman I guess that's a question
for the Department yes and he he will be
coming up next terrific thank you very
much thank you are there other questions
yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Burkey
um online six
um if upon reading it
say If an employer under at 15 or more
does not have an accrual policy
it looks like current time shall be paid
in a prorated basis is that is that
starting a benefit for that because
there's no policy or is that
delineating what a cruel and earned time
is
I was just want your take on that
I'm sorry if there's 15 or more if
it's my understanding reading this that
if I'm an employer with 15 or more
employees that I must have that written
policy
and and to your earlier question
representative Abalone
when you were asking about the seasonal
individual
um I think that that too could be a part
of that policy
um in terms of the relationship between
um thank you for clarifying that and if
the employee happens to go back to the
employer
always panel all their time and they're
starting again this would eliminate the
ability for that employee to say okay
well hold on to my vacation time I know
what's a month laid off you know I'll
you know we can hold it over until I
tell I'm rehired because you know it's
the form of four weeks off because they
shut down or something like that would
that eliminate that ability for that
employee and an employer to enter into
that agreement
I would have to think about that I'm not
sure all right thank you sorry
any other questions yes representative
colcom is that nope okay
I don't see any other questions so thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you
um and as I said I have one final card
if someone could pass the blue sheet for
HB 74 forward
and we welcome Deputy Commissioner Ogden
from the Department of Labor
thank you representative seaworth uh for
the record Rudy Ogden uh Department of
Labor
um I'll just go through some of the
questions that have come up obviously if
there's other questions I'm happy to
take those as well
um first in reference to uh commissioner
Rawlings House's Point uh following
along with what he said while I
ultimately agree that it could be and
would be disputed between attorneys I
think ultimately his question about how
it would be handled for payout of those
folks uh that he said they're paid the
three days for years of service we would
see that as not being problematic
relative to this language this language
for the proposed legislation does not
seem to create a new benefit since
instead speaking to instances in which
there is a benefit provided so if the
present payout process for separated
employees from unclassified Services is
they get three days of pay that's not
creating earn time or on on time that is
unused rather it's just creating a
payout at separation so I don't see that
as being problematic to be clear
ultimately it could be disputed speaking
to disputes representative avalani's or
the question had come about but if is
there I forget who would ask that
representative McKenzie about uh is
there opportunity or standing for folks
presently that is what happens and what
I mean by uh that's what happens now is
right now existing law as was stead
stated by representative Cahill is that
policy controls policy or practice
control so if an employer has written
policy or has a standing practice or
there's a combination of both policy and
practice that is what controls if the
employee feels as though that has been
violated or something has not happened
that should have happened they can and
do file wage claims with the Department
as representative Cahill brought up we
frequently are called on these issues as
you might imagine when folks separate
from an employment they oftentimes say
well what happens to my time even if the
employer has a policy I will say a lot
of employees
they might not read the policy they
might not fully understand the policy or
they might just disagree with the policy
so again we get a lot of calls of the
calls that we get a certain number
ultimately do result in hearings so to
be clear there presently is a process or
a platform in place whereby individuals
can have those disputes uh brought out
representative avalani your question
about the line in line seven and eight
in the absence of an accrual system earn
time shall be paid on a prorated basis
again the Department's position on that
reading this language as is is not that
that creates a new benefit we would see
that language as being simply
informative for purposes of how the
payout under 5A would happen we're just
seeing that it's not saying okay even if
they don't get time they're going to get
this payout we would see it as saying in
5A it talks about there being a payout
and we would look at the language above
and saying okay if they if it's not
accrued there's going to be a proration
of the payout based on how long they've
been there
so I'm happy to the only other thing I
would point out and this wasn't directly
asked but it's come up in previous
um iterations of this bill is the uh
instances or occasions in which there is
an acquisition or a company changes
hands that does come up and just to be
clear what the department can and cannot
do if a new entity buys an existing
employer we are not entitled or
authorized to then hold past practice
against the new entity we can and do go
after that old employer but oftentimes
as you might imagine when someone sells
their business The Entity that's been
sold that becomes defunct and it is
difficult to get money out of a defunct
entity but to be clear the department
can't go to the new employer and say new
employer you're on the hook for time
that should have been paid out so I just
want to be clear because that question
has come up in the past of how we handle
those instances again what we would do
now is if the policy was that time
should have been paid out we would look
to hold the old employer reliable but
that's not always possible especially if
they dissolve or in some other way
disappear
so I'm happy to take any other questions
all right thank you other questions
representative McKenzie
can you um give us your opinion about uh
we know that
the contracts come in different forms
the written contracts and then there are
oral contracts verbal contracts it can
be they can be agreed to by employers
and employees have you ever had a
instance where there was a verbal
contract that came before the department
no I think most off the top of my head I
can't remember one most often if it's
not written then what happens is the
practice is what is referenced so it's
instead of saying what was said the
first day I was hired they look at what
happened when other people separated
from employment so representative
McKenzie I can't say that that's never
happened but in my direct recollection I
can't remember us going off of a verbal
only
one quick follow-up follow-up so the
burden then become is on the employee to
prove past practice correct or the
department if it was something the
department was doing on its own motion
yes thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman good to see you
again commissioner
um
the
some employers front load their time
earn time vacation time or anything like
that
um under this would they be entitled to
the full amount
um say they loaded up on January 1st say
February 1st they quit would they be
entitled to their full complement of
earn time even though they technically
haven't accrued it and again I think
that is what the language in seven and
eight are speaking to is that if there
was some front loading so if it was a a
you know one tranche given uh at January
1st where again in seven and eight where
it says in the absence of an accrual
system earn time should be paid on a
prorated basis I believe that the payout
would be prorated I believe that's the
intent of that language certainly I
don't mean to speak for representative
Cahill but that's the Department's
any further questions yes representative
thank you Mr chairman
um Deputy Commissioner do you think that
if this passed it would make a company
aware of the law and probably recognize
the problem before they sold it or would
interesting question I'm not sure if I
can fully answer that I will say that
there have been instances where we've
dealt with employers that
they're not thinking of that in the
process of selling their company it does
not come to mind so I don't know if that
answers the question I can say it has
come up where it's been something
overlooked oftentimes people selling
their companies there's a lot going on
there's a lot they're trying to figure
out and sometimes this is an issue
that's lost
follow up thank you Mr chairman but but
by passing this there'll be one more
thing for them to look at before they
sold the company so they would be aware
of it
or they would recognize it and do
something about it
correct I guess yes it would be an
obligation to look at it thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for Mr
for uh taking my question
if this law were to pass in the case of
a company sale where the old entity is
going defunct do you think this law
would help at all or would the defunct
entity still be you wouldn't be able to
get payouts from them even if this law
existed and it was more clear that they
there could still there could always be
difficulties in collect I mean anytime
you're trying to assert or uh seek
recovery of monies there's always
difficulties in collecting those so I
imagine there would still or could still
be difficulties I think the uh most
important piece in terms of what's
operative language here is the fact that
it's strictly saying if there is one of
these transitions in ownership uh it
should be taken care of before that is
fully effectuated I understand what
you're saying if it's ignored it would
it would still be an issue to collect
follow-up follow-up
do you see that language in the bill
that says it should be taken care of
part of the transition as imposing a
requirement on the new company the per
the company that's acquiring it is there
a
is there a responsibility for the new
company now being created by this bill
no the only responsibility I see here is
where it talks about the fact that the
time could be transitioned over if
that's how it was arranged then it would
be viewed as the new company taking on
that responsibility but I don't see this
language as imputing responsibility to
the new entity to take on the liability
for payout thank you
thank you Mr chairman so if if the old
company sold because there was a
bankruptcy coming up and they sold their
assets
would these people be entitled to a
claim such as lost wages of lost earned
wages
would it be into that category of
thinking of bankruptcy
I mean if there's owed money in the
context of a bankruptcy they they would
be entitled to file a claim in terms of
order of Precedence I'm not a bankruptcy
expert but I don't so I don't know how
that would sort out but if they they're
deemed which they would be deemed as
owed money they'd be creditors they
they'd have a claim that could be filed
arguably all right thank you
I see no further questions so thank you
very much for your contribution that was
the final card on this
[Music]
um
I'll read out we have online 16 people
signed in to support this bill none were
opposed
and in person seven people signed in
support and two were opposed
and with that I will close the hearing
on HB 74 our next hearing for hb82
starts at 2 30 so we'll stand in recess
it looks like 2 30 so if we can get
so I will open the hearing on HB 82 this
is relative to employment protection for
participants in the therapeutic cannabis
program
and I would ask the sponsor
representative Vale to introduce the
bill and
um if you haven't if a pink card isn't
on the way before you leave make sure
you fill out a pink card for the record
thank you Mr chair
um good afternoon there should be a pink
card along the way oh great great
um for the record I am Suzanne Vale of
Nashua ward 3 which is Hillsborough
County six and I'm here today to ask
your committee to consider my bill House
Bill 82 which will give relief to
patients of the therapeutic cannabis
program by sending the bill to the state
house floor with a positive
recommendation
um you may be familiar with this bill
has come before the committee I don't
believe the last term but the term
before
um and I just wanted to let you know
that I'm open to working on this bill
and to any amendments that you may find
necessary to put this in the place where
the Bill's intent is most represented in
some some states uh protect employees
who participate in their therapeutic
cannabis programs but in that in New
Hampshire there are no explicit
protection for programs for employees
who participate in our state's program
they may be at risk of termination or
other adverse employment actions if
their participation is discovered versus
acknowledged and as legitimate Medical
Care where they're covered under HIPAA
Provisions they're not covered
necessarily if they have a positive
urine screen during their employment
pre-screening process or in the course
of their employment when these tests are
acknowledged as necessary and
contributed to their humans or human
resources
portfolio on the person typically during
a urine drug screening where there are
substances that are prescribed
are only are detected the lab will call
you and they will ask you
um is there a reason why this medication
is in your you have a prescription can
you provide us with information
this is a pre-employment drugs cleaning
we are required to release these results
to your potential employer and when the
potential employer gets these results
they're going to see this substance on
um
so when you're not able to do that
you send this proof to the lab but when
you're not able to do that we don't have
a provision in the law then we can't ask
for a lab to clear us for therapeutic
cannabis to work in an industry where
that is not necessarily
um indicated
there are places in the statute on
therapeutic cannabis and I have sent you
around a handout that has
information on the restrictions that are
already placed on people that are
participating in the therapeutic
cannabis program in the law
so as far as contradictions or
contraindications between certain types
of Labor and certain types of heavy
equipment these things are enumerated
and the um the process for
storing keeping managing and using your
medication are really up to you like
so
here's my story this actually came up
for me as an issue
and I am a patient in the therapeutic
cannabis program in the state of New
Hampshire and I have been since 2017.
a urine test was required by a company
then I wanted to work for over the
summer
and it this company was based out of New
Jersey
New Jersey has laws in place where they
protect medical cannabis participants
from discrimination in the workplace
they have a thing called the Jake honig
compassionate use medical cannabis act
signed into law in 2019 and that
prohibits employers from taking adverse
employment actions against employees who
are medical cannabis participants
this includes non-hiring terminating or
otherwise discriminating against
employees based on their status as a
medical cannabis participant
they are also employers are also
prohibited from taking adverse
employment actions against someone on a
positive drug test and the use is in
compliance with the State Medical
program is taken into consideration
so in my case nonetheless I went and I
did the urine specimen the employee
reported that they would like to take my
my test which the company had to report
to this potential employer in New Jersey
and they could not exclude it they said
we can't clear you for this so I I said
we'll just go ahead and we'll see what
happens and if they don't want to hire
somebody based on their own state law
and they don't want to protect people
who are working remotely based on their
own state law we can at least look at at
what's going on with ours
so I waited and I waited three weeks
three and a half weeks and this is time
where I could have used the income and I
was hired but I never felt like the same
as if I hadn't opened my medical record
to my potential employer and I felt that
this was a way of trying to reduce risk
at a time when we really need people in
the workforce that have skills and know
how to do a good job and that
discriminate to somebody on the basis of
cannabis when it is part of your medical
regimen and in many cases a very serious
illnesses
um that can only be controlled in some
ways in this manner
so in this Society where we hire and
fire according to a patchwork of state
laws we have to refer to how others
states have solved this problem
we don't want to systematically reject
people or workers in a world that we
can't keep up the Business Without
humans right now we're really suffering
because we don't have the people between
the machines and because we lost many
laborers to this pandemic
it's all a big it's all a big um
recipe where we need workers and that's
what we have to focus on how much we
need workers
there are several folks here to testify
today what I wound up doing in response
to my situation was I contacted OLS and
I said I think there was a bill in the
past that was filed that had cannabis
protections for people who want to use
the therapeutic or you just even want to
try it to try to get their lifelong
problem under control so that they can
continue to work and not lose their jobs
they can embark on it in the middle of
employment and it doesn't have to be a
conversation the person has with the
employer when they walk in the door
and it doesn't have a lasting effect
like the job I left because it just was
very uncomfortable after
having waited to see if they approved me
or not knowing how qualified I was
so again there are several folks here to
testify today and if I have said
anything that they need to correct I've
asked them to do that and if you have
other questions we'll be listening While
others testify I'm happy to take
questions it turned out that I had been
a co-sponsor on this bill and I did not
remember that I had
and the primary sponsor was
representative Wendy Thomas who I would
like to give most of the credit for this
bill because if it it just would never
have occurred to me and I was like wait
a minute we need to do something about
this especially when it hits home and I
am so sorry that it wasn't somebody that
came to me it was me that came to me but
I can tell by the interest in this bill
that this is affecting other people and
they wanted you to consider it so again
please thank you so much for your time
and attention and
um I'll take any questions that you
might have all right thank you very much
are there questions
one of the things that was passed out
it's got your name on it
um is this document that refers to
section 126x colon 3.
where did this come from
this this is uh this is the RSA 126. yes
okay that is I'm so sorry I just pulled
out that one section I thought I put one
I thought I put and I don't have that
one with me right now
thank you
other questions
yes
thank you Mr chair
um I'm just wondering are there any
other prescription drugs or
non-prescription drugs with these sort
I don't know what drugs specifically
have Protections in the state law but
what I do know is that when you have a
urine drug screen and it's a marketed
drug that's prescribed to people that
depending on again depending on whether
you're operating heavy equipment or
whether you're in a job where all of the
other things and the snippet of Statute
that I sent around the room
so all of these things are the same if
you were to take Oxycontin or oxycodone
but those are medically prescribed
[Music]
um
I'm just going to call them pills
they're just they're they're
and so what winds up happening is that
they say do you have a prescription for
this the lab calls you you go back and
forth with the lab you don't disclose
anything to the employer you disclose it
to the lab and you say oh yes I have a
prescription for that they will tell you
what kind of proof they need for you to
send in
in order to
do what they call clearing you for
employment
oh
so uh I'm not very familiar with the
pers the Cannabis program uh I got I got
to hear but is there actually a
prescription for it or how does that
work so like if a lab asks you know do
you have a prescription for cannabis do
you provide like do you provide them
that and I know you said that they still
had to show it to the employer but I
okay
if if this is beyond you I there might
be somebody coming up next that can
answer it better whatever you're
comfortable with but
thank you
um thank you I'm hearing that someone
else wants to answer that
um thank you if you don't mind waiting
until the next person does I have an
answer but it's probably not as good as
Jerry's
okay anybody else have questions
seeing none thank you for introducing
the bill
thank you so much for taking the time to
hear my bill
and as we've all been mumbling next up
we'll ask the honorable Jerry knurk uh
back with us he is on the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
and he has provided some written
testimony and asked to speak for three
more of an overview of the therapeutic
what I was doing Wendy obviously has
first dibs because she's just she still
is a rep and I'm not but we're both
trying to ping pong between this and a
committee downstairs
yes so um as the chair has said
um I served as a state rep and I still
serve as a chair of the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board so I
can give some input into this I also am
a retired orthopedic surgeon
um so the issue is that in its November
22 meeting the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board uh I should
explain what that is that's a group of
about 10 providers along with a patient
representative who is also here to
testify and
a representative from the atcs the
dispensaries we worked together to
provide oversight in the medical aspects
of the therapeutic cannabis program and
in the November 22 meeting we considered
this bill and we voted unanimously in
favor of the concept we didn't worry
about parsing out all the language
because we're not Labor uh in Monks we
don't know that stuff as well
point is cannabis has been demonstrated
to be of oh by the way I did distribute
the written testimony you all have it I
did it before
um therapy value in a number of
conditions such as pain PTSD and others
now to enroll in the program you have to
be certified by your medical provider
that you have one of the qualifying
conditions that exist in law
so you're certified for it
the prescriber does not prescribe
cannabis we cannot do that because it's
a schedule one drug schedule one drugs
are drugs which ostensibly have high
abuse for potential and have no
therapeutic benefit of course that's
actually kind of nonsense because we
have cannabis derived drugs that are
approved by the FDA so it's the DEA
needs to get their act together but they
haven't done that for a long time
so they certify that you have a
qualifying condition
and then once you're approved by the
therapeutic cannabis program you're
given a registry ID card
that enables you to enter the
alternative treatment center or ATC
those are the dispensaries where you'll
receive counseling about the appropriate
strains and about the roots of
administration that might work best for
you and that's where you obtain the
therapeutic cannabis
the therapeutic cannabis program
provides valuable educational and
therapeutic benefits to over 13 000
patients in New Hampshire and the
majority of the patients to qualified
are patients between ages 50 and 70. the
vast majority are in the working age
group
about 82 percent of patients have
reported that they are able to reduce
their prescription drug use
over 70 percent of the patients are
certified for treating pain
and that often allows them to either
lessen or actually avoid the use of
opioids and I followed up I was not able
to to certify back when I was still in
practice because the law wasn't in yet
but I followed up with some of my
patients and some of them who I could
never get off opioids because I did back
pain stuff so
um we're able to get off opioids using
just an occasional dose of cannabis and
they were free of them
so it's important to understand though
that patients who use therapeutic
cannabis they use it to treat a disorder
they do not use it to get intoxicated
intoxication is not the intended effect
it is a negative side effect
the strategy that we use the patients is
to start low and go slow so we start at
a very low dose and we titrate that dose
upward until the person reaches their
therapeutic benefit without any toxic
side effects if they do then they may
have to try to change to a different
strain or something like that because
again we're working for function we
relieve the pain so the person can
function if you make them intoxicated
they're not functional you've not done
your job so we're trying to find that
happy medium of the appropriate dose and
you know you'd be amazed to find out
there are a handful of are well our
fellow I guess I can't say that anymore
your fellow Representatives who are
members who are patients in the
therapeutic cannabis program happily
serving and doing a good job
so there are two ways that therapeutic
cannabis patients actually face
discrimination in comparison to patients
with other prescription medications the
first one has to do with unique
pharmacokinetics of THC
THC is a psychoactive component in
cannabis and therapeutic cannabis will
contain differing amounts of THC some
will be high in THC some will be low in
THC but the point is that when you take
THC it is fat soluble it binds to the
fat in your body and then it is very
slowly released and then excreted in the
urine and the issue is that you may
still test positive for THC even if you
haven't taken any cannabis for a week or
even more if you're using a fairly high
dose
so the issue is that the mere presence
of THC does not denote impairment
and uh this is very different that we
see in opioids opioids are not fat
soluble they're basically in the
intravenous and intracellular space and
when you find an opioid under routine
testing that indicates recent dosing if
you find therapeutic cannabis it could
have been a week ago so think about the
person who took a some therapeutic
cannabis the night before to treat their
PTSD or their pain problems they get a
decent night's sleep they come to work
the next day they've still got THC in
their urine if they took an opioid it
wouldn't be there so that's one way that
it's a little bit difficult the second
though is what uh representative Thomas
sorry representative Vale was just
speaking about
um they are discriminated against in
terms of how the case is handled when it
comes back with a positive test for THC
so consider that hypothetical of a
patient taking opioids for pain
and the versus taking therapeutic
cannabis
the DOT drug testing employee notice
states that if you test positive and
opioid but you present a valid
prescription the medical review officer
will report the result of your test to
your employer as negative
that person's disability will be
accommodated but no such protection
exists for the patient using therapeutic
cannabis because back to your question
there is no prescription that's why this
bill refers to the certification card
not a prescription
now the New Hampshire Supreme Court
already addressed this issue in 2022
with their unanimous decision and the
pain Scott Payne versus right-of-way
Incorporated case Payne was using
therapeutic interesting name actually
but he was Payne was using therapeutic
cannabis for PTSD and he requested
exemption for routine drug testing is a
reasonable accommodation of his
the Supreme Court stated that RSA quote
RSA chapter 354-a does not contain any
language categorically excluding the use
of therapeutic cannabis as an
accommodation end quote
therefore their employer by the way
while we're at it the 126x that is the
therapeutic cannabis statute that's what
established the therapeutic cannabis
program so that's what that is when it
got distributed
um so therefore the employer uh the
Supreme Court said the employer might
have to consider therapeutic cannabis as
a reasonable accommodation
the New Hampshire Supreme Court ruled in
support of equal treatment for
therapeutic cannabis patients this
doesn't preclude the need for this bill
because we need to put this protection
into statute so that thousands of
therapeutic cannabis patients don't have
to go through litigation to have their
disability protected
I do have a recommendation regarding
what I see is one flaw in this bill and
in this sense I'm not speaking for tcmob
because we did not parse out the
language since we are not diverse in
labor law but um this is my view lines
seven and eight of the bill
they State this section shall not apply
to employment where drug screening tests
are required for the safety of persons
and property at the job site
that is a loophole so big you can drive
a truck right through it
and that's a problem because any any
employer could just say you know uh it's
important in my business I don't want
you to do that and they're completely
undercut the goal of this bill
so I would recommend amending this to
keep it compliant with federal law and
federal rule
but remove that option of any random
employer exempting themselves by the
language I've put in which would be to
strike the part that says required for
safety or persons and property the job
job site and have it say shall not apply
to employment or drug screening tests
are required by federal rule or law
therefore you're still covered by the
Omnibus Transportation Act which says
that pilots and anybody in the
transportation sector have to be tested
law enforcement all that kind of stuff
plus also as I understand there was a
rule that was made that said that
federal employees could not use cannabis
or any other kind of drugs so this would
make us not so keep us compliant with
federal law which is important obviously
but it would be I was thinking of making
a laundry list but I didn't want to make
a laundry list because as we know then
you exclude certain things that you
should have put in or whatever the
government's already done that for us we
can just uh the federal government we
can just defer to them and I kept it
vague and didn't refer to the Omnibus
Transportation bill because that might
get changed this way we don't have to
change the statute every time the
federal stuff changes so in summary if a
patient is found to have THC in a drug
test and they have a current valid
therapeutic cannabis program registry ID
card
then that drug test should be treated
just the same is that they were found to
have an opioid in their drug test and
they have a valid prescription that's
all that's being asked by this bill
again with the usual exceptions to be
compliant with federal law
I'll take any questions thank you for
your testimony I do have a question
um thank you for
making the suggestion about the federal
law are you aware is there any place
remaining in state law that as a state
we require testing for certain
professions that I do not know
um because I think and I think that the
sergeant and I were speaking about this
earlier I think that they for the uh for
law enforcement I think that has covered
federally anyway so we're all set on
that one
um obviously if in the testimony if we
find out that there is a state issue
then we might have to put in some other
exceptions but I think this would
probably cover it though I'm no expert
in labor law
other questions representative Lowe
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um when you made the uh the statement
about line seven here uh line seven and
eight
um I've been involved in dangerous
employment and uh how would you
differentiate between someone who is
using record uh can't uh
not recreational uh therapeutic cannabis
and maybe recreationally too
um you know that I I see a problem there
like I said I've been involved in
dangerous employment and I don't want
somebody's you know Stone putting up
staging on the side of a house for me
and I go up and it falls down yeah
there's a couple of things about that
number one is
um
you know it's the the issue would be
that we would hope that you would pick
it up refresh it back up there's nothing
in the
um in the 126x it is stated that there
is nothing that it would uh allow
nothing in that statute that would allow
a person to actually be uh intoxicated
during the time of their employment and
in the labor law stuff that I was
reading in in D.O.T or when the from
when the labor law law firms they were
saying you know if you see the person
they reek of cannabis uh their bloodshot
eyes they're not they're slurring their
speech
that's a different issue then they're
impaired we're not just talking about a
positive urine test and then you'd have
to handle that differently and that
would be a separate case
um in the bill
It also says that in eight lines eight
and nine and ten nothing in this section
should be construed to require an
employer to allow being impaired by
cannabis products but it's the same
thing for recreational let's say you are
a recreational user and you used it a
week ago and haven't touched it since
that time your drug test could come back
positive and you're perfectly normal
this is the big problem in law
enforcement for driving impairment
testing is that we do not the the urine
tests and blood tests are not great in
terms of they don't measure impairment
they just measure the drug
but basically it lines eight nine and
ten already say that you can't we're
compared
follow-up
I guess my question would be is is there
any test or any tests in the pipeline
okay that uh that would differentiate
between the guy that smoked a bone
before work or at lunchtime okay and
Andy's got this card sitting in his
pocket okay um you know is there
anything that'll differentiate no there
are no markers in therapeutic cannabis
um it is oftentimes highly refined and
maybe uh extracts and tinctures that are
that have been developed but that they
still would still what's being tested
for is a metabolite of THC and depending
on the dose or the level of THC that
would be there one this is one of the
issues with uh the hemp stuff that we
went through just a few years ago the
federal hemp law says it can't be more
than 0.3 percent THC to be legal for for
him but you have to be very cautious
because if you're just using CBD oil I
might have a little bit of hemp in it a
little bit THC I'm sorry and you could
flunk a drug test so uh but there's no
way to discriminate that there's no
marker in the therapeutic cannabis
but by the way that would be the same
thing as a person who might have a
prescription for an opioid but they just
happen to also be buying street drugs
and taking that on the job and being
impaired it's really no difference
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh good to see you
again thank you
um
we're gonna dovetail off of what
representative love said nothing uh
sections a number to excuse me sentences
8 9 and 10. nothing in this section
shall be construed to require an
employer to allow being impaired by
cannabis products while at work
um during a testimony you said that it
was difficult to
um determine a level of impairment
police officers and whatnot so now we're
leaving it to an employer to decide
whether they're impaired or not and if
the employer decides to dismiss them for
the day or dismiss them from the job
because they seem to be impaired this
would give them the ability to go to
Labor Commission and say I wasn't
impaired that day there'd be no test for
it yeah they know that would be another
set of that would be a whole separate
type of case and I'm not quite sure how
to resolve that
um I there are some very highly
sensitive jobs that use some types of
cotton neurocognitive testing that look
at reflexes and in your cognition to be
able to test a person for impairment
from any Source
um and uh but we do not have that
routinely available to test impairment I
mean because you give them a you know a
field sobriety test see if they passed
that but you'd have to Doc the employer
would need to document that
um but I mean again it's the same thing
for an opioid
or an alcohol I mean if you're doing if
they're at work and they are uh
the drunk
what would you do then
you know huh but there's Marcus for that
say what there's Marcus for that you
would smell it yes but outward things
but if there was a base follow-up yes
if there's a baseline of
intoxication because of medical
marijuana and they're at work you're
leaving it to the employer to say well
you're imperative you're not impaired I
mean and then by the time it gets to
labor department it's weeks later
there's going to be no testing there's
going to be it's going to be he said she
said and then it's going to be well that
would be the case from what you've just
laid out with the
with alcohol you say you smelled it on
his breath but you don't have a test you
haven't proven that you didn't do
breathalyzer test so unless you do a
breathalyzer test which I think most
employees aren't going to do employers
aren't going to do so as a result
um it's still going to be he said she
said situation and so I think that would
be a it might be an indication law on
that one right but you
oh
they would still be um markers for a
talk for alcohol intoxication work well
if it were two days later there's no
market for alcohol either in fact there
would still be for THC perhaps but there
wouldn't be for alcohol and so the THC
person again would be discriminated
against even though at that point
they're you know Stone Cold's over right
yeah so this is this is the where I say
it's the the physiology kind of makes it
a little harder with THC that's just a
thank you representative Edge
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
person a used cannabis a week ago
person B used cannabis 10 minutes ago
can you explain what symptoms or markers
may help distinguish a person who is
very obviously intoxicated versus a
person who would still register for a
urine test
um symptoms including like you said
um I I don't have it with me for that
reference although I think there's no
solid things but I think the things you
might use would be the same things that
your local
um police officer might use you know
bloodshot eyes slurred speech difficulty
with uh coordination
um ordering a pizza while you're talking
to them a few other things like that
that might say this person is currently
intoxicated with cannabis but the thing
is again the great majority of our
patients they're using it they're not
trying to go for intoxication I mean one
of the this is one of the stigma issues
we see in therapeutic cannabis people
think they're a whole bunch of stoners
these are people again the primary age
group age 50 to 70 and these are people
that are highly functional people
including many people in the legislature
and uh they're they're not looking for
intoxication
thank you Mr chairman um my employer is
Dartmouth health and if we have an
employee that comes in and we suspect
they are intoxicated we have a fitness
for Duty test
um
I just want to clarify that it is not
impossible to discern whether or not
somebody is intoxicated without your
analysis correct I I think you can
usually get a pretty good hunch as
representative avalani pointed out you
know if there's a reek of alcohol and
and there are some signs that uh many of
us might know from having seen somebody
who's intoxicated with either alcohol or
cannabis but I think it's again still a
rather similar situation and in cannabis
those kind of unfairly singled out even
if or an opioid if it came in with an
opioid and you're sitting there falling
asleep in the corner
um you know you might be a little
suspicious of course impairment can come
representative colcum
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question thank you for taking my
question I actually now I have two
um is there currently a a lawn place
that prohibits an employer from refusing
to hire somebody because they're on
I I'm not an expert in law I would a
labor law as my understanding though is
that if for certain jobs such as if
you're an airline pilot I'm not quite
sure that you would be allowed if you
had a positive test even if you had a
prescription that part is above my pay
grade I don't know
um
so I don't think you required now
um when answering the previous question
uh you you made a comment that there are
many representatives that um are taking
therapeutically well a few I should say
not many but they do have statistics on
how many representatives that you
believe are taking therapeutic cannabis
um I know of about
four or five
and representative veal just commented
that she's out of 400. yeah
but I mean you can remember we have 13
000 uh registered patients uh in the
stage yeah
um other questions
to that point
um
honorable former representative
of the current uh
legislature how many of the 400 roughly
do you know
um well current I don't know because
some of these are people from a couple
of years ago I'm not sure if they're
still serving but
um
I know I can count at least a few that
I'm aware of and I would certainly never
reveal the names their business to
reveal the name
any other questions over here
representative adjutant you have another
one thank you Mr chairman uh
representative or excuse me former
representative
um it takes a while I've had a hard time
I had to change the h-o-n it was it was
not easy uh the therapeutic cannabis
program is within the RSA correct yes
RSA 126x follow-up
uh so just to refocus the conversation
would it be correct to say that we are
discussing the ability of individuals
who are following a stank say State
sanctioned
cannabis health related program to
engage in work provided that it is not a
mechanical operation or safety risk is
that we are simply allowing those people
to work within the state sanctioned
program is that correct that's a very
good wording thank you
any other questions
thank you very much thank you everybody
good to see you all again good to see
you
um next up I would
representative Thomas uh who is a
co-sponsor of the bill uh obviously
speaking to support for five minutes she
asked me I probably won't even take five
minutes
um it even though my name isn't on
printed on the bill I I believe I am a
co-sponsor however there was some
confusion at OLS
but I am on it okay excellent
um because I should be on it um this
this is a bill that came up uh two terms
ago
um and it was received actually pretty
well
um before I start I would like to just
make the point that New Hampshire does
not have a medical marijuana program we
have a therapeutic cannabis program
and I keep hearing people
um uh use the same at its medical
marijuana is not in New Hampshire we
have therapeutic cannabis okay so um my
name is Wendy Thomas I'm a
representative for the town of Merrimack
uh Hillsborough 12. I am a mother of six
I am the executive director of a
non-profit that advocates for the
disabled Community I work in the Energy
Efficiency field I volunteer for our
local Historical Society
I'm a State Rep
and I am also a therapeutic cannabis
patient
for the last five years that there has
not been one day one day that I have not
taken cannabis
it has controlled my pain and as a
result I have not taken any opioids for
chronic pain since starting the program
and prior to starting the program I was
on something called a pain contract and
I was given 120 oxycodone tablets every
month
however because I am a therapeutic
cannabis patient there are some jobs
that I cannot hold because I wouldn't be
able to pass a drug test
I could use prescription opioids and
alcohol until the cows come home
but I wouldn't be able to take a micro
dose which is what I take which is 5 to
10 milligrams
and the effect is about four to six
hours
and I take that at night to help me
sleep because I would test positive for
cannabis for up to 13 days after I took
that dose
I do not enjoy being high and I put that
in quotations because the proper word is
inebriated
but the microdoses that I take control
my pain and it controls my inflammation
now I'm not talking about someone who is
obviously inebriated at work that's
actionable for any business to take
actions against just like if somebody
showed up drunk
the therapeutic cannabis program is a
legal program and patients have some
legal protections we're allowed to
transport the Cannabis to our homes
we're allowed to keep a certain amount
in our homes
it's also a self-regulating program
we know that if we abuse this privilege
our cards can be revoked
that's nothing that anybody wants to do
and just as an aside I used to work in
one of the dispensaries and I never felt
safer um in in the dispensaries because
everybody knows they have to behave
there's first of all a million cameras
but everybody knows this is a privilege
and it could be taken away
so with this bill it's time to give more
legal protections to this vulnerable
population so that they can get on with
their lives and remain in the workforce
and that's all we're asking
let us get on with our lives and stay
working
thank you I'll take any questions thank
you for your testimony are there
questions uh
uh representing someone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um you were very specific that we do not
have a medical marijuana program but we
do have a therapeutic cannabis program
what's the difference
wording wording there is there is some
discussion that the the term marijuana
is considered racist because it's
actually the the Mexican term for the
the drug and so by using marijuana
you're you're enforcing that it's a
brown people's drug
but the wording in all of our rsas is
therapeutic cannabis we do not have a
medical marijuana program thank you
oh oh yes representative Granger to you
oh that was your question all right are
there any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you I'd like to call next
representative Newell who is also a
hello
um thank you for allowing me to speak to
you today uh I don't think there's a
whole lot that I can add Beyond uh a lot
of what everyone spoke to before
um but when I look at this issue in the
way that cannabis is treated a little
differently than other uh therapeutic uh
Pharmaceuticals and things like that I
can't help but think that it kind of
stems from a stigma around the use of
cannabis and I'm very familiar with that
um stigma the reason being that I lost
my children's father to heroin overdose
14 years ago on Christmas Eve my fiance
at the time and I remember a whole lot
about the stigma of substance use the
interesting thing is is that we have a
wealth of information in studies
recently that
uh would indicate that a cannabis can be
very effective in the treatment of
substance use disorder of opiate use
disorder particularly
um I think a lot of times we look at
um we look at cannabis use and we think
about as she referred to someone getting
high there are a lot of people who
cannabis use returns them to normal to
functioning and I just think that we
should kind of take those things into
consideration especially when we have
such a problem with the overdose crisis
here in New Hampshire so this can be
something that can help people and if it
returns you to a state of functionality
being able to function in society and
obviously this bill does cover a variety
of
kind of uh it it uh frames it properly
so that uh certain things that we might
be concerned about clearly we don't want
somebody going to work in being not
functional but if cannabis helps people
to be functional uh I don't see the
problem and I think this bill covers it
pretty well
thank you are there questions
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
next I would like to call co-sponsor
Representative silbert
um seabird
ah
deny sorry
my apologies
hi and I want to thank everyone for
hearing me today or being willing to
listen
um like like she said I think a lot of
stuff was technically covered that was
in my um testimony originally
um but just a few things I wanted to
point out really about people that use
um therapeutic cannabis to be able to
you know have be able to continue
working and contributing to society
without discrimination and this is also
for the hiring process of jobs also so I
just wanted to make that point so
and I think that's it actually all right
thank you any questions
I see none thank you for your testimony
next I would like to call Elizabeth
Sargent who is representing the New
Hampshire Association of
Chiefs of police has signed a neither
opposed or in support of the bill
hi good afternoon uh chairman members of
the committee my name is Beth Sargent I
work for Champion and capital group here
in Concord
um a prb for you this afternoon
representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police
um the Chiefs reviewed this bill and
they just wanted to comment on the same
section that representative Canuck
talked about lines seven and eight and
what they would ask if this bill were to
move forward is that there be a specific
carve out for law enforcement
and I can't answer all of the questions
that were asked by the committee members
but certainly if you wanted to hear from
law enforcement a police chief or a drug
recognition expert we could arrange for
that
and so that's all I wanted to say thank
you I I do have a question if I don't
know if you know or if maybe you can get
back to the committee uh
former representative suggested that the
law enforcement might be covered under
that category of federally required is
that in fact the case we might be yes so
I'd like to see that
so if it is
if if it's not clear
um maybe you can clarify for the
committee whether a blanket statement
about Federal rules would include law
enforcement or whether that needs any
sort of special treatment or state law
we'll find out and get back to you for
sure
are there any other questions
do the Chiefs of police have a position
on uh the use of other drugs uh in the
workplace
trying to think how to answer that
question
um certainly wouldn't be supportive of
using drugs in the workplace no
so somebody that's treating for back
injuries follow-ups Jim so somebody is
perhaps treating for other pain
conditions uh is there a screening
process the chiefs of police go through
oh okay um screening people that are on
various drugs that are prescribed I am
not sure about that we've not talked
about that thank you
representative Sullivan
I guess they've got a request I'm not
sure who it goes to but basically
um it's been recommended that we put the
the federal reference into the statute
um because the feds have already created
the laundry list of uh exceptions
um is can we get a copy of that laundry
list uh
uh yeah representative shares testimony
with me and we will certainly I'll share
that with the Chiefs and we'll get back
to you if that would be sufficient
you can we hear from Jerry
yeah yes if you could uh are there any
other questions uh before
she finishes okay if you can come up
again
no I don't I don't have the original
Source but as I understand that the
specific job role is regularly classed
as testing designated positions
requiring free employment checks under
the Omnibus Transportation employment
testing act include Transportation
Railroad and Aviation Personnel law
enforcement agency heads political
appointees
where'd that come from
employees authorized the use of well we
get elected not appointed employees
authorized use of firearms employees
with security clearance to access
classified documents and information and
employees involved in rehabilitating
drug users interesting
um but that says the roles that are not
classified as testing as designated
positions but may still be required uh
would include social workers Healthcare
professionals Pharmacists and
firefighters
um
but this is from a
a
a page which is not it is not from the
document of the Omnibus transportation
thing so I cannot vouch perfectly for
the uh veracity of it
follow up could you uh send that to the
committee please yes sir thank you
and it has also it also has a link to
the Omnibus Transportation employee
testing act which I'm sure if we weighed
through all three thousand Pages you'll
probably find the list somewhere
because I don't know that's usually not
allowed but I just had that answer for
you
a CA that is here that the National
Guard folks probably also fell under
that same federal law well they would
under
um under uh authorized and use of
firearms
that makes sense yeah thank you
all right thank you for uh bringing that
to us
next I have representative Perez who is
going to speak in support of the bill
thank you again I don't think I I need
to introduce myself again because I've
been here in this seat like three times
um I'm here to support this bill as
someone who
um
doesn't use cannabis but
use CBD
I have a chronic lyme disease
uh from chronic lyme disease I developed
um I'm someone who suffered from PTSD as
well
I um I'm a Survivor of sexual assault
I believe that um
if I had the choice or if I have the
opportunity to use cannabis
I will use it let me tell you
as someone who have chronic pain I have
days that um
I have to ask my husband to help me to
get out of bed
um
moving
I have days that um my joy hurts very
much
but I always afraid
that I will apply for a job
that requires me to go through uh drug
testing and not pass drug testing and be
disqualified to get the job because I'm
using cannabis for pain
but I'm someone who struggled with pain
from the day the time that I get up in
the morning until the time that I go to
bed I'm in pain 24 7.
I have days that I wish
um I can utilize the Cannabis but like I
always remind myself
how about if you get laid off on your
job
and you need to apply for a job
in one of the qualifications is you you
have to go through drop testing and even
though that you have this medical card
but you still then probably not gonna
qualify for the job
that's one of the reason that I'm
asking you to support this bill
is someone that in which
can utilize the Cannabis but I haven't
right now I'm in pain if I go to the
hospital right now and they ask me
can you tell me for one to ten
how can you tell me how high is your
pain I will tell you that I have eight
I feel like tremendous pain right now
coming from my feet all the way to my
neck I feel like I'm getting numb my
body is getting numb
but I'm afraid to take any pain
medication
I don't take any pain medication I can
tell you that I take maybe one Tylenol a
day
and that's all I take because I'm afraid
that's why I'm asking you to support
this bill for people like myself
that we wish we can have the opportunity
to use the Cannabis but we are afraid to
use it for now thank you for your
support
thank you for your testimony any
questions
seeing none thank you again I have one
last card we were promised that the
patient rep would testify so Heather
Marie Brown
hello good afternoon
the red light should be on of your own
there you go there we go hi there how's
everyone today thank you so much for
allowing me a few minutes to come up and
talk to you my name is Heather Marie
Brown I am the patient representative on
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board I
represent every single therapeutic
cannabis in the state of New Hampshire
currently I try to be their voice I try
to express their thoughts and what their
opinions are
and in this situation I will tell you
that this bill will impact at some point
in time every single individual that
currently holds or will be seeking a
therapeutic cannabis card
I think that the root of this bill is
wonderful I think that it is long
overdue and it is something that should
be addressed
we have hundreds if not thousands of
patients that could potentially come off
of disability or public services and
rejoin the workforce
in the areas that they were trained and
have skills in but because they are a
therapeutic cannabis card holder they
are not able to do so and it kind of
hinders them you know I had heard
earlier someone testify about having a
card is a privilege and we're worried
about losing our privilege I would like
to take it one step further and tell you
that has a therapeutic cannabis card
holder
I myself have agreed that if I violate
the therapeutic cannabis program in any
way shape or form I will be charged with
felony charges
so although yes it is a privilege I want
you to understand what a therapeutic
cannabis patient is actually doing when
they join the program they are agreeing
to follow state law and and program
rules and regulations and if they
violate those rules or regulations they
will be charged more harshly
than an individual who does not possess
a therapeutic cannabis card and I think
that's really important for people to
understand because that shows the degree
of responsibility that a patient is
taking on when they join this program
and I think that should be acknowledged
I think that that is a very important
factor to consider you know we are not
just looking for an Avenue to be able to
use
cannabis and get high or have a good
time or anything like that we are
accepting these responsibilities because
we want to make changes to our lives we
want to be able to rejoin society as
functioning individuals
we are constantly held back
discriminated against and ridiculed for
our choices to use therapeutic cannabis
especially in the employment Arena I
heard questions in regards to how many
state reps use therapeutic cannabis
currently well let me tell you that for
the few that publicly admit to using
therapeutic cannabis and holding a card
there are so many more individuals that
will not admit it publicly because they
are afraid of the stigma and the
discrimination and the possible
potential in some cases retaliation
against them and that is unfair
um I do myself also have concerns
with seven and eight that this section
shall not apply to employment where drug
screening tests are required for the
safety of persons and property at the
job site now
I don't know all the big fancy words I
don't know all the big fancy terms but
what I can tell you is that this
basically allows an employer to say that
any position or job that they have
within their business falls under this
category so a shopping bag packer at
dumoulies could fall under this category
you know I think that that either needs
to be removed or even
expanded to include a caveat on
following federal regulations in regards
to what positions require
drug screening
personally myself I will tell you that I
would love to be able to get to a point
where the state of New Hampshire just
removes cannabis all together from the
list of
things that can be tested for
using drug testing I heard questions in
regards to you know is there a way how
are we supposed to monitor this how can
we determine and I will tell you that it
is very easy to distinguish an
individual who is incapacitated and
Under the Influence whether it is
therapeutic cannabis alcohol
opioids or any other substance they're
going to have poor work performance
they're going to have their
communication skills going to be
impacted their visual
impairment is going to be extremely
noticeable I will
foreign
I personally have one area where I
consume my cannabis because I am a
mother of three children so I choose to
consume in an area safely that my
children are not allowed to be in
so I would honestly not use the word
smell anywhere in this because you don't
have to consume cannabis in order to
have the smell of cannabis on your
clothing you can literally just be in an
area where cannabis was or has been
consumed because like cigarette smoke or
like many other air pollutants it does
absorb into clothing and it it can
absorb into the areas so it can
kind of linger for a while so to speak
I think that
this needs to happen I I think that you
need to look at this bill along with
every other representative that's going
to look at this bill make the small
changes that we've suggested making and
do this because we
you have the opportunity
to peel a layer off of discriminating
against therapeutic cannabis you have an
obligation to your constituents to
protect them you have an obligation to
help promote Financial Freedom and
success and accountability for an
individual and this is one step to do it
we deserve these protections we deserve
the chance to be able to return to jobs
and positions that we have currently
been held back from because of our
choice to better our health
um I want to thank you all and I am more
than happy to answer any questions
thank you very much are there questions
seeing none I thank you again for your
testimony if someone could pass up the
sign-in sheet for 82 I'd appreciate that
and
law enforcement actually isn't under the
Omnibus Transportation Act it's under
the executive order from Ronald
reagan12564 I'm composing an email to
you we'll direct you to it I pulled it
up and it's uh it's listed in there for
law enforcement that's where that
resides all right thank you
it does that apply to Firefighters
he mentioned that the firefighters was
not required but the federal law allowed
right
that again is from a um employment blog
which I cannot vouch for the veracity of
that this other part I've actually found
in the stand in the executive order from
so before I read this
um we obviously had some suggestions for
changes today I also
uh now appreciate this is an issue that
can get complex as it's an interaction
of federal law state law existing court
cases
um and I'll say I had a discussion with
the chairman last night about this and
we think this should go to a
subcommittee to help us understand these
issues better
since the chairman gets the big bucks
that I don't get I am going to leave it
to him to appoint that subcommittee but
I guess I'd ask the committee to plan on
that being what where we take the bill
if someone has an interest in that uh
feel free to email or message the the
chair and
um as as we put together who will serve
on that question please go ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh we're going to
hear from the Department of Labor on
this
they did not sign up uh to speak on it
but if you want to ask a question and
have the department answer it you you
could do that
all right so if you could come up and
if when you're done you could fill out a
pink card so we can put that in the
foreign
thank you representative yes
my name is Tracy McGraw I'm an attorney
thank you Mr chairman thank you attorney
McGraw
sections three of the line stream Forest
is no employment show tonight employment
however seven eight and nine talk about
nothing in the section shall be
construed to require an employer to
allow being impaired by cannabis
products while at work how would the
yeah basically what we're talking about
here would have to
have navigation we'd have
we'd have termination as to whether or
not there actually was an intoxication
or
um an incapacitation shall we say of uh
the therapeutic cannabis or whatever the
positive drug test was section 14 under
281 a of the workers compensation act
talks about personal uh fault and
employee fault in the workplace as far
as the cause of an injury and that also
incorporates intoxication
there are there's been a lot of
discussion about different kinds of
medications that people are taking while
they're at work there's been discussion
about the safety of those what has to be
proven under 281 A14 is that the actual
impact of the drug alcohol and or in
this case positive therapeutic cannabis
did that impact or did that cause the
injury that occurred at work so it's
almost a two-fold test that has to be
met pursuant to that particular statute
it's not just that it was a positive
test but did it actually cause the
injury that occurred I know that wasn't
completely your question I might have
you repeat it just to make sure that I
understand and I I get your answer as
best I can gonna go away follow up thank
you that was my next question as to how
workman's compensation would look at
that as well if they were impaired while
at work and got injured or injured one
of their co-workers would workman's
compensation
a cover this and B would the employer be
on the hook for allowing the employee to
work impaired
with causing injury at the workplace
okay so I'm going to refer back to
section 14 of the workers compensation
act so it's 281 a colon 14 if you want
to look at it it's not entitled
intoxication it's entitled employee
fault
but looking at that and the way it's
looked at at a department level hearing
is number one if the employer is aware
that the employee is intoxicated knows
that they go out at lunch time and and
has some form of alcoholic beverage or
or another type of intoxicating item and
they allow that person to come back to
work the employer cannot then use
employee fault as a defense against a
workers compensation claim they the
employer may be on the hook
the next level is what we discussed a
few minutes ago is that was that
intoxication that impact of whatever was
taken did that actually cause the injury
all of these things have to be
determined in causal hearing at the
Department of Labor and there would be
basically there would be a burden of
proof on both sides that would have to
be required on that
thank you
thank you any other questions for the
Department of Labor what if I have a
question uh the term intoxicated yeah is
thank you thanks this is fancy stuff now
I do
um intoxication uh if I understand
you're right that could be a pretty
broad sweeping kind of thing it's drugs
it's alcohol those kinds of things
correct yes thank you
anything else
thank you very much for stepping up for
us
with that I will close the hearing on HB
82 I have the uh written sign-in sheet
there were one two three four five six
seven uh signed in in row and there was
one signed in an opposition
if we go to the online sign-ins we had
18 signed in in support and two signed
in opposition
and we've gone over our time so I will
immediately
open the public hearing on HB 118.
and I
I set aside my title so I won't read
that right now and instead ask the prime
sponsor to introduce it
and there it is this is prohibiting
employers from engaging in certain
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is rep
Josh adgerton uh representing the
wonderful town of Enfield in the New
Hampshire house
bring before you HP 118 a bill
exclusively aimed at leveling the
playing field between employers and
those wishing to organize their
co-workers in labor
last year I co- I co-sponsored the wrong
Bill to accomplish this task
last year I co-sponsored a bill that
would ban outright employers from
putting on anti-union rating sessions
these training sessions occur often at
the point of higher as part of an
employee's regular onboarding in that
individual session an employee often has
to watch a video in which a friendly
looking actor tells the employee that
our company is a family and that if you
hear Union chatter tell your supervisor
the video from an Amazon shift lead
training teaches leads to listen for
words like living wage Steward and
bathroom breaks
after that the video is often depict a
gruff-looking man in a leather jacket
and a mob-like accent trying to cast
organizers in a negative light
while these sessions occur during the
hiring process they are an effort to
preempt organizing
they are often employees first
impression and we know that first
impressions are important
if an organizing effort does occur these
sessions are opted often captive
audience and ratcheted up
an employer can mandate employees to
attend them they're on property and
they're on the clock
while the employer can hold staff
captive to make their case organizers do
not have the same opportunity
the legislation last year was wrong
because it attempted to ban these
trainings outright it was clunky and
hard to enforce all this bill does is
make it a choice
employers will say the choice to
organize is the employees alone
but if one party can fire you for
insubordination if you won't attend
their cheerleading session and the other
isn't allowed on property is that a
choice
I completely understand the desire of an
employer to argue a union isn't
necessary in their specific best
interests and that's why this is an
option bill
with this law an employee gets a
stress-free opportunity to give a fair
hearing to both their employer and labor
organizers
they get to feel good knowing that they
made an informed decision about whether
or not to sign a union card I would ask
that the committee move this OTP and I'm
taking I can take any questions thank
I see none so thank you for your
testimony
next I would ask Jan Shafer
testifying on her own behalf in support
my name is Jan Schaefer
um I won one large two three sorry thank
you uh my name is Jan shaper I live in
Warner New Hampshire
um and I um thank you for allowing me to
appear today to give testimony on this
bill
um I am retired but I spent 30 years 30
or more years of my life
um working helping workers organize
unions
and I think the sponsor of this bill
just gave a really uh straightforward
look at
um what would make uh organizing
more would level the playing field
um currently
employers can
force workers to go to meetings
and
can then
really tell them pretty much anything
about the union the union all Union
meetings are held off site
um the unions generally are not allowed
in the work site
um
and these meetings can be pretty
intimidating to workers
um
and I actually just wanted to talk about
two campaigns that I worked on that had
very they had the same result but the
atmosphere was really different
um they were two Hospital campaigns uh
one with nurses
um both of them with nurses
one of the hospitals hired uh at Great
expense on anti-union Law Firm
I think they spent over three million
dollars on this law firm and they had
mandatory meetings nurses were forced
on while they were at work to go to
meetings to hear
um all the reasons that the union was a
bad idea
um the employer went so far in this case
as to actually pay someone to make a
film
um about strikes a particular strike in
Vermont the film was edited
um put the Union in a horrible light and
there was no recourse to
correct the record at that point
um they the nurses did vote for the
union they won
um the other hospital was a slightly
smaller hospital but they did not hire a
anti-labor law firm and their meetings
were completely voluntary
as were the Union meetings well
actually the word the nurses didn't go
to either meeting they didn't go to the
employers meeting and they didn't go to
the union meeting but they did vote for
the union
they obviously felt that they had enough
information to make an informed decision
and they chose to be represented by a
union the anti-union sector of our
economy in 2019
um was 340 million dollars I believe
um so it's a big industry and
um it is intent its intent is to
intimidate workers into not joining a
union
um
you know you hear a lot about oh I hear
often about you know unions are a thing
of the past right
but unions have changed a lot the
conditions for workers haven't changed
that much there are still reasons that
workers choose to join unions
um it's not always pay sometimes a lot
of times it's about respect for the
nurses in both situations it was about
short staffing they wanted more Staffing
um
but I also think we're looking at a new
time not just for unions but also for
employers and I have for you an article
from the Harvard Business Review that
was just written about new ways for
employers to interact with organizing
drives
that keep up with the times and I think
this bill is a really good first step
towards modernizing
how organizing takes place thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you again
next I would call David Juve
representing the Bia he is going to
oppose the bill and he needs to speak
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee again for the record my name
is David Juve I'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry Association we do
oppose the bill I think there are
several problems with it one is that I
think this is attempting to regulate
employer Behavior at the state level
that is already
addressed by the National Labor
guides both employers and labor
organizers on what they can and cannot
do relating to organization so I think
this would be if it were passed it would
be preempted by federal law
secondly I think it is
dancing around the issue of free speech
I understand that this is relating to
requiring an employee to view a video
but it uh
at least is tangentially related to free
speech and I can almost guarantee it
would result in in litigation under
um First Amendment Free Speech rights
and then finally I just want to point
out that the fine of ten thousand
dollars per employee seems excessive if
you're a company and you have a hundred
employees which is not a large Company
by any stretch of the imagination
and the Department of Labor and
enforcing this new law found you
out of compliance that's a million
dollar fine
if you have a if you're a larger company
say 5 000 which is not unheard of in New
Hampshire that's a 50 million dollar
seems a little excessive so that
concludes my testimony I'd be happy to
try and answer any questions thank you
very much are the questions
thank you for taking my question Mission
duvet sorry
um could you Enlighten us as to how the
um uh the uh
nlrb
um addresses these types of meetings
the National Labor Relations Act I
can't spell out in detail what the
provisions are but I could certainly
provide that to you that'd be great
representative McKenzie yes
I got it
the uh
I have particular interests in what you
said about the question of free speech
um and if you mean by free speech that
employer can lock somebody in a room
while they're working and basically
require them to listen to to tapes or
presentations by people do you consider
that to be free speech
I consider it
um enough of a gray area that it would
likely result in litigation
follow-up
why would that be
because you're impacting the ability of
an employer to pass on information that
they deem necessary or important
important to the employee and I guess
in some ways I I understand how you
phrased your question but I really doubt
that the rooms are actually being locked
and I further would note that this bill
refers to anti-union training I don't
know of any anti-union training it could
have just as easily been called an
education session
representative thank you Mr chairman um
thanks for taking my question when we
talk about free speech and the employer
has a captive audience and they won't
let them leave
Wouldn't It Be Free Speech to allow the
other side equal time to give their
point
again I think the National Labor
Relations Act stipulates how the other
side has the ability to contact and
communicate with employees that they're
trying to organize
I don't think there's any requirement
that the employer invite them into the
workplace
follow-up thank you Mr chairman
um
but don't you think they should be
required to offer the same amount of
time and let the employees come at their
will if they don't want to hear it they
don't have to but at least offer the
same amount of time on an issue
no I don't think that
thank you Mr chair
um are there any laws against uh
trainings generally or uh any of these
quote unquote four-store coerced
trainings uh in other topics that you're
not that I'm aware of that you some of
you who have been around here for more
than two years might remember there was
a proposal two years ago that initially
impacted private sector employers that
stipulated they would be prevented from
conducting training programs on
diversity and Equity
that language was eventually changed
although components of that exist in for
education for example that's the only
thing I can think of
thank you
thank you Mr chair
so you have an issue with the language
that says no employer shall require an
employee to attend or participate
you have an issue with that
only to the extent that if the National
Labor Relations Act allows employers to
require then yes I would have an issue
all set yeah I think so for now any
other questions
uh just for the record I think that
there's a distinction between the
National Labor Relations Board and the
law that governs public employees in the
state of New Hampshire and they're not
covered by the National Labor Relations
Board
so you're speaking just yeah yeah thanks
that's an excellent clarification and I
appreciate it I'm speaking on behalf of
anything else
thank you very much for your testimony
um oh I'm sorry
but not with him
can we we can loop back later if you'd
like
uh it might be more appropriate if it's
a discussion for us to leave it till our
our session
or you're the boss
thank you and thank you again for your
testimony
um I have one final card and so if
someone could pass up the blue the the
final remaining blue sheet and
representative Perez again has
asked to speak and on her own behalf for
this bill she asked for three to four
minutes in support
thank you again
um again my name is Maria Perez
um said representative from District 43
but I'm here speaking as someone who is
a union member twice two different
experience
I I was a union member as an organizer I
I've been a community organizer a couple
of times
and my last experience is an organizer
my co-workers
voted for me to represent them
I do have an issue when
um
you employee
has um someone from management
come to the meeting where only employees
supposed to be and make a decision
where ours as an organizers should be
impacted by the decisions in our meeting
come to find out that this person who is
coming into our meeting in bringing all
and these other persons make the
decision to sign a contract without us
taking final the final conversations and
decisions before we sign the contract
that affect a lot of the employees who
were temporary employees or contractor
employees
I'm asking you to support this bill
because I believe that employees
should
have the opportunity to be able to be
part of a union without the employer
have someone in in and at the beginning
when we get higher like someone else
said it previously
we get to sit down in a room
and they told us how bad is to be part
of the Union
they told us the bad things about being
a union member
but they should allowed the union to
come in and talk to all all of us even
then so they can understand you know
they even they have rights is it
managers because it's two different four
union members it can be one group for
the organization can be just management
and is one group is employees
but sometimes people may misunderstand
or get confused
and you know in some time from try to
hurt employees they hurt themselves as
well
so I'm asking you to support this bill
because it is time for us to recognize
that Union's been here for longer longer
time
and there's nothing wrong to being a
union member and I'm proud to continue
to support unions thank you so much for
your time
seeing none thank you again and that was
the final card that I had
um
I have the sign in sheet there were 15
signed in in support of this bill or
signed in against and online
uh there were 28 signed in in support
and four signed in against and with that
I will close the hearing on HB 118 and
that was our last scheduled hearing for
the day so unless
anyone has any
further comments or questions uh we have
another set of hearings scheduled for a
week from today last I heard we're not
having a house session
I we should know that by now uh so I
that's sweet hey what do I do with this
foreign